hello everybody hello hello i am i still have a fucked up
sleep schedule i know it's been a week plus it was
originally jet lag and then i never attempted to fix the jet
lag so now it's just me flipping up my time zone i'm now i'm
now technically in asia right now my sleep schedule is based
in I just didn't fix the jet lag.
So I've accidentally fucked over my entire sleep schedule
because of it.
Have you tried sleeping?
The crazy part is that I was tired at a actual NA time.
And then I was just like, I'm just going to power through
it.
I was like, wow, I'm tired.
I'm tired.
like 11 p.m.
should i a go to sleep b uh lie down for a bit and then
maybe i'll eventually fall asleep or c stay at my pc i
wonder what option i picked there and so so a little bit of
an oopsie and the thing is my body gave me two chances
because it happened for two Two days where my body was like,
you know what?
Maybe she didn't notice that she was tired at a normal NA
time.
Maybe we'll give her another one.
We'll try this again.
Hey, Doki, your body's telling you, you're tired.
Or D, play Rink on the PC since you're there anyway.
Might have actually picked D.
And like, maybe she just didn't notice.
We'll send her another signal tomorrow And then I noticed it
The thing is, I did notice it And then I was just like Just
one more game of Overwatch Ring Surely that's alright
Whoops Also Also So yeah, I woke up at 4.30 Not the best
time to wake up I could have slept more I will be brutally
honest with you guys wanted to sleep more, but that was
like, I got a stream.
I got a stream.
It can't be a mess right now.
I can't tell chat, guys.
I have to push the stream because I'm still sleeping.
I can still be like, you're still sleeping?
It's 5 p.m.
Do you get thinking for the super chat?
Thank you.
Sleep is for the week.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, also, own health month for this month um i was like
oh it doesn't seem so bad like like um i mean do have like
like one one thing that i have to work on behind the scenes
but then that april seems no sponsors nothing nothing like
too um uh too like exhausting or something and then we got
reached out by several sponsors because apparently um uh
another of their client had to drop out and it was like and
then so then like some clients dropped out of the sponsor
due to scheduling conflicts and I think I assume they were
like let's get jokey she says yes to everything because she
loves money and they're right and she'll say yes to this
last minute to be done by end of April and they're right I
was just like are you sure you think I was like, I can do
this.
Yeah, I can fucking do this.
And so now I have a, um, and they weren't wrong.
They were not wrong.
I do say yes to everything.
Um, so it's like mid to end of April.
There's a lot of, well, well, leading up to it, there's a
lot of stuff to do.
You guys will know.
It's all coming out on April.
It's all, my God.
think I'm so easy and by God they are right so so it's my
own personal helmet that I solely constructed that I put
myself there I was just like I barged in and I was like
don't worry I'm a regular up hey guys thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you also in case you haven't seen
appears that Mexicans found okay thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you so um yeah so that's that's that
also the reviews for let's just do a world update the
reviews for the new mario movie came out today and wow they
are not good they are pretty bad so apparently as a
currently from the reviewers i i don't know maybe it's like
a kid's film and then like you know the people who review
the movie on children, but they're pretty bad.
They're pretty, they're pretty fucking bad.
It's like a 45% rating right now on Rotten Tomatoes.
I think for those who are going to the movies tomorrow to
watch it, maybe that's why it's on April 1st, because the
entire movie is a joke, but maybe, but like, just go in with
no expectations, because let me read you some of the reviews
for this the super mario galaxy movie review bland screen
saver of a movie that's actually worse than ai at this point
it's tried to say that a bad film feels as if it's been ai
generated but this simplistic sequel is next level it's
nothing more than an easter holiday cash crap i get like
they're like it's literally worse than ai um and there's
another one his name is Kevin Mayer from The Times, the film
is torturous to sit through, and for me, provoke periods of
actual physical discomfort.
Okay, and there's this one.
This one's my favorite because The Times, all the other
reviewers, they gave them like, you know, 5 out of 10, 6 out
of 10, 7.5 out of 10, 3 out of 10.
gap the times gate they gave zero out of ten and you're like
damn zero like did mario murder his mom or something that's
that's like that's pretty low zero is pretty low like what
the fuck is what the fuck is going on with that review and
then um the times the film is torturous to sift through and
for me provoke periods of actual physical discomfort i had
to stab my repeatedly in the hand with a pen to distract
from the howling distress it's that bad
i was just like holy oh my god bro i'm sorry mario actually
killed his mom or some like i thought i was just like damn
drew my house just like what the zero out of 10 and this guy
is willing to stab himself with a pen so i hope the mario
movie is not complete ass but it does make more sense why
it's released on april fools um you know what's not a joke
though perfect segue by the by the way you know what's not a
joke wait let me see if i can where did i save this where
Give me a sec.
Be on standby for the punchline, guys.
Be on standby.
Give me a sec, guys.
Let me a sec.
I forgot to save it.
You know what?
Because I just copied and pasted on Twitter.
You know what's not a joke, guys?
Give me a sec.
Bam!
Tomorrow!
It is a swimsuit reveal.
Trumple, please.
Yes.
Surprise.
Tomorrow, it will be a new outfit reveal.
And this time, it is swimsuit-themed.
Yes.
Swimsuit-themed.
And it's going to be tomorrow on April 1st at 5 p.m.
PST.
I swear.
dad's life that it is a swimsuit no fake out whatsoever guys
this is real i know i could have waited and put this skin
suit at a different time but i got it like like uh yesterday
and i was like i'm just gonna i'm just gonna rip it tomorrow
i'm just i know it just was a coincidence that it was also
tomorrow is april 1st but but i was like you know what I'm
just gonna rip it.
I don't have much plan for it.
It's just gonna be BAM!
Here it is.
I just didn't want to wait.
I was just, I want to show you guys.
We're finally gonna answer the question.
How much was the sports bra holding out on?
Why would you doom dad's life like that?
Give us a clue.
The clue is that it's a swimsuit.
It's that not enough for you guys look i literally even gave
you guys a silhouette and you guys all are like that can't
be real it's it's a little silhouette of the new outfit um
so anyway maybe debut it no it has to be on april 1st oh
thank you for chat thank you thank you i have trust issues
because you what makes you think i'll believe you when you
have done me wrong thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you rice thank you the super chat thank you why are
you naked it's a swimsuit i'm not gonna be fucking going
into the ocean with my shirt on like like that doesn't make
sense have you ever gone to the beach and okay someone has
they do go out in the into the ocean with their shirt that
might not be the best comparison um but you know what I
mean.
You know what I mean.
It's a swimsuit.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm looking forward to Doki Borg 2 Electric Boogaloo.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The only thing I'm worried about is whether or not YouTube
will take the video down.
That's the only hit I'll give you guys.
Told you it's not a joke, guys.
It's an actual swimsuit reveal.
It's a real swimsuit reveal.
Get ready for tomorrow, chat.
Get ready.
um don't get me oh ducky ducky thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you is this one of those nude beach they
have in europe they even super chat oh someone was like now
she's trying to i will show you this message of me talking
to my manager and being like do you think i'll get banned on
youtube for this
I literally wrote this and I'll give you like the timestamp
too.
So you know, you know, I was talking.
I'm, this is not a joke when I say this.
When I, there you go.
That's when you know this is no joke no more.
Like, this is, this is no joke no more.
I literally wrote this message to my manager about this.
dm we're just making up messages now um pat your s says
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you simple
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm sorry
dokey i could tell there is nothing up there thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you director thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you to be fair a scuba diving
suit is also technically a swimsuit they use super chat
thank you thank you all right let's act let's move No date,
no evidence.
It's literally last night.
That's why it says 2.41 a.m.
Because I sent that message at 2.41 a.m.
today.
All right.
Anyway.
It's time to play Content King.
For those who don't know what Content King is, it's
basically a streamer simulator.
um okay wait uh
sorry i just got like an update on a behind the scenes thing
let me respond to this
let me respond to this real quick i just i have to i have to
respond it's for something else guys this is something else
and i need a i was just very caught off guard with what i
was being said So give me a...
You'll find out about it.
You'll find out about it later.
Give me a sec.
Sorry, I gotta go back to work mode real quick.
I got a lot of work stuff.
I'm so over...
I'm so...
Came back from vacation and I went straight into like, what
if I just do everything all at once?
What if I have 10 fucking plus projects, um, not to work on
simultaneously, uh, so, so it's a lot, guys.
I actually was, like, last night, like, yesterday on my free
rest day, it was just me working on projects the whole
fucking day.
Um, I also need to record some stuff, too, after today's
stream, because I was planning on doing it last night, and
then I played a couple of big games of Overwatch.
Guys, don't do open queue.
Open queue is a fucking joke of a system.
And I was like, let me try open queue.
Open queue is fucking terrible in Overwatch.
It's like, literally, like, I had a game where it was all,
like, it was six support players.
And I felt like I just got went through PTSD of my old days
where, like, there was no roll queue.
Yeah, who the fuck, that's the thing?
Who the fuck plays open queue?
You don't understand.
only grinds open queue and he was like top 30 or something
in the leaderboards but like you know how the leaderboards
is just grind to win it's just grind to place and so he had
like he he like he was like masters or some shit yeah he was
like masters one and he was top 30 and i was like that is so
sad that and i would not even masters what i don't even know
it was like masters and Open queue is just so fucking weird.
It's such a weird system.
I know it's just like when there's no roll queue, it's just
weird.
It was just all over the place.
I'm just so used to, I'm just so used to having a roll
queue.
Um, let's see.
But it's classic.
It was a horrible system.
That's the reason why we got roll queue.
all right let's see uh let me do let me respond sorry let me
respond to this real quick
all right there you go all right anyway content king um oh
yeah they also made sure that you can't pick more than two
tanks it literally restrict like you can you're like people
are like what do we just have a team like be like four tanks
and two supports they literally fucking restrict you so that
you can only pick two tanks but you can't escape from triple
support you you can have triple support the amount of teams
i played against triple support was crazy so i you know
what's crazy i my i placed higher in open queue than i did
in roll queue because like Okay, this sounds really...
This sounds like mean, but the skill level in OpenQ, the
average skill level in OpenQ, is a lot lower than Roll Q,
because I placed GM in OpenQ.
I placed GM in OpenQ, and in RollQ, I placed Masters 3.
who could have known like it was I literally jumped into GM
and and I'm basically in the top hundreds if you judge look
at rank wise that's literally top 100 in open queue it's
looking wild it's actually fucking wild anyway let's go to
content king so for those who don't know what content king
is um it's basically a simulator to be a streamer like oh
what what would it like to be an irl streamer um so like
everything is content and you're just making content of
everything i i personally am not like a huge fan of the, of
the, I guess, like the popularity of, uh, IRL streaming now,
due to the fact that, like, some streamers are, like, super
invasive when it comes to IRL stream.
There are good streamers, good IRL streamers, but, like,
everyone wants to be a streamer now.
So, like, they would just pull their cameras out to
everything.
Because apparently, what I remember was, like, like,
apparently TwitchCon, um, uh apparently at twitch con there
was a lot of irl streamers but that they were just filming
everything to the point where like you know the regular
guests couldn't like actually walk around and do like normal
stuff because they'll just be pulled aside but by an irl
streamer but that's just my personal opinion i just think
like um the streaming etiquette has sort of like not existed
um because you know sometimes people don't want to be on
stream you know like like some regular people just want to
be regular people that's just my opinion on how iRL
streaming has has developed now and i feel like um it's
actually wild because i don't know if you guys know but a
lot of kids these days when they're asked like what do they
want to be when they grow up number one is a streamer
I'm, you know, when I was growing up, I was like, I want to
be a zookeeper, but now, like, the children are like, when I
grow up, I want to be a streamer.
Like, so that's just a little concerning.
Just, just a little bit.
Like, um, you're a streamer, so, yeah, but I, like, stumbled
my way.
into being a streamer.
I wasn't like, I don't wanna be a stream.
I'm gonna fucking making my entire career path to get there.
I literally just sort of like stumbled into it.
I was like, I tripped and fell.
I was like, I'm gonna do this.
And I tripped and fell and I rolled down the stairs.
And then bam, hello, I'm Dokeybird.
Welcome to my channel.
This was not planning.
This was like, oh, I have free time.
Let me just stream for fun Into de-stress
Alright, let's see Oh, display voice actor I guess, oh yeah,
because they got like actual streamers To voice act this But
anyway, now it's time To live my dream on what it's like to
be An IRL streamer Say, tap view count Constantly decreased
requiring an Urge search for content Divine Punisher, any
viewer loss from bands is increased dramatically.
Unmoderated hell, only two moderator slots available.
It's like, yeah, I don't need PTSD.
I don't need trauma.
I'm thinking about numbers right now.
All right.
All right, I don't know what Sound Guy is here.
But like, let me go.
That's dramatic.
Oh my god.
Am I streaming this?
Am I streaming this from the bottom?
Is that my mom?
Oh, is it too loud?
Let me There we go Maybe one moderator slot hi This moment
isn't great, but I wish my stream could see it Oh, that's
good this moment He's amazing.
It's true, though.
I wish our stream could see it.
That is true, though.
Like, people are, like, streaming.
Wait, Kai Sinat?
You came out of retirement?
I wish my stream could see it.
Hmm.
What if you could capture every moment live on stream
without having your hands tied?
Introducing the Sky Sinat's live streaming drone by me.
Kai Sinat's with motion detection technology, face
recognition, built-in Wi-Fi.
You can follow me everywhere!
With negative latency, with the Sky Synapse live streaming
drone, every moment is an opportunity.
See, this is why you retire.
Every moment is an opportunity.
Wait, I'm...
Wait, I think I get it.
I think... I understand now.
I...
no wait guys every moment is an opportunity guys
no we're losing it no put that virtual suit back on you're
digging in are you serious if you're gonna stay here to
stream yes you have to put money into it
oh shit chat is no longer in slow mode total mob helpfulness
total mob tab total mod strictness all right let me know if
the sound welcome or i have to be left side doki apparently
because we gotta be able to re-chat give me a sec left side
doki where does she live she lives right here a dead one
currently it's your mission to gain viewers and climb the
ranks of the oh that's easy let me find a year i think i
need new mods i i need like i i think i need a mod um all
right um i think i think i need to buy v bots
is that what everyone isn't that what all the big streamers
do nowadays like not me though not disclaimer i mean like
the big big ones not not me i'm not like the big big one not
me though not
continue your life as a streamer a day and one is your
mission to gain viewers and climb the ranks of the streamer
world go find some content uh press one in chat if you are
if you are a view bot oh shit one dollar what's your mom
going on about oh my god my one viewer gave me one dollar
yes i'm gonna be rich so soon guys my chat is totally
authentic there is no view bots look at my authentic
conversation that my chat is having right now like yes it is
i um stacy one two three i am a real person here to watch my
favorite streamer right now playing content king uh okay let
me there is no sensitivity here what do you mean there's oh
we control there you go it's my control why the fuck do you
it's just one thing authentic conversation your service bots
could not follow our user guidelines oh Give me, so let me
tab out real quick and fix something.
Wow, you are so funny.
Ha, ha, ha, where can I subscribe to you for more of this
wonderful content?
Well, if you look below, you can see a subscription
subscribe button next to the bell.
Make sure to hit that bell button for all future
notifications.
10 000
yeah every moment is content it's an opportunity it's for
streaming i told you already i'm gonna be a streamer kated
you know i don't understand whenever you talk about the
streaming thing have you started your college application
yes yes get off my day about it type bro type just making
sure you don't want to miss Oh, you want it louder?
Okay.
Uh, Harvard.
Why do you care so much?
You went to college and you don't make...
Oh, shit.
They get grounded.
That's quite mean, Caden.
I ain't capping, mom.
Everything we have is because of dad's money.
If you weren't so broke, maybe he would have stayed when I
was born.
i'm gonna double down that's right this is good content guys
this is and you talk to your mother like that but think
about the content i can't show my viewers i'm a pussy bam
there we go you just gained viewers look at that your
dialogue choices throughout the game can sometimes ward you
with viewers or punish you with a loss thereof choose
carefully see i told you guys imagine the content the
viewers knew i knew the viewers and then we'll enjoy that
that's type shit bro that's that what guys every moment is
an opportunity
fuck that an alpha like me doesn't pop anyway i'm gonna be
moving to kick real soon that's it doesn't an alpha like me
doesn't apologize to no one recording us too turn it off
nope this is my life now i'm gonna stream everything they've
been to make documentaries about me on god on god jesus
christ the crazy thing is like the crazy thing is that like
people talk like that now like some kids actually talk oh my
god three viewers three fucking viewers we're making it oh
my god i'm gonna hit the top 10 the top 10 most subscribed I
want to go find content around the house what do people want
to see me do oh I can skateboard okay I can't skateboard can
I open anything okay that's a problem it isn't a joke no
more all right why am I Wait, what?
What?
Oh, space!
I was just like...
There we go.
We're about to cook some filet mignon.
I don't know.
Alright, guys.
It's a cooking stream time.
We're doing some type shit, bro.
Wait, did I put in a microwave?
What do you guys think?
Oh, I'm so clumsy.
God, oh my God, guys.
I'm so stupid.
This is cringe.
The thing is, people like cringe now.
Stream the pub, like, okay, I'm going to get banned for
that.
It's raw.
We're X from Y right now.
Is there another?
Oh my God, actually, I have to stream that.
Wait, hello.
What the fuck is this lag, bro?
Yo, Sky Synapse.
Make sure you get my reaction and shit.
Oh my god.
This fight is insane.
What a crazy fight.
That's right.
We also got to do overreactions and everything.
The step-by-step guide on how to stream.
Don't get me streamed.
What are you doing back?
All right.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
All right.
I'm gonna drink my water with a fork All right.
Boop, boop get in here.
I'm about to drink this whole fish tank with a fork LMAO
That's right.
I'm so quirky and stupid.
The content was so 2020, bro.
Step out and eat that motherfucking swish fish.
Hey, one dollar is one dollar, guys $1.
It's technically dead.
Look, it's on the side.
But you also gain certain choices may increase or decrease
your notoriety.
If you reach, you will be suspended from streaming.
Guys, it wasn't.
Aida fish and still nobody to...
Hey, $1.
Hey, he said nobody is watching, but he gave me $1.
So, got your first toxic donation and chat message.
And we'll rage bait you and decrease your sanity.
low sanity will trigger adverse effects that alter gameplay
you can add moderators and your challenge deal with toxic
viewers uh papa thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you and keep you seeing go to your computer to manage your
minds all right wants to be modded looks like your audience
practicing oh we gotta get that guy out of here affects your
helpfulness improve sanity damage control reduces notoriety
and strictness manage toxicity but affects viewership you
gain access to more mods with unique effects as your
viewership increases uh add moderators if um i don't know
just type one oh i only have auto mod i'm not i'm not famous
enough yet it's okay it's okay guys it's all right that's
enough content for today they'll regret it they're gonna
regret being mean to me all right sleep stream time save and
sleep all right guys We're doing a sub-a-thon, but it's all
sleeping.
It's a sub-a-thon stream, but it's all sleeping.
You cannot be for real.
Go outside.
Do I have another?
Okay.
All right, let's go.
Hello, Sarah.
What?
Oh.
Oh, Crank up the game volume.
Sigma.
Me.
crank it up on discord no fucking way is that the new
streaming drone you bought one looking course bro every
moment is not is an opportunity hell yeah bro i'm a streamer
now yeah i'm low-key a content guy too you're about to hear
my name everywhere that's right kaden okay i need to get an
actual streamer i can't be doxing myself as my username that
minus one for immersion who the fuck calls themselves kaden
and brentley like all right let's see i started streaming
too but all my viewers are just trying to get me to fucking
gamble but follow me follow for follow you might throw me a
follow bro i made a new all right i'll put it up a little
bit it's kaden brentley now dude ain't no way you got the
full government name yeah no that's what i'm saying bro
kaden you're a fucking idiot like you gotta have a streamer
name dude you're a fucking dead streamer how much did you
spend for that drone no one's even watching you get
defensive bro my stream was just having connection issues
and that isn't my real viewer oh shit i should have been i
should have like been nice to him so i kept them as a viewer
that's cat bro but i'm still rooting for you you gotta have
at least 100 viewers if we're gonna real or not anymore do
people see that now so you're streaming now nerd oh shit oh
it's tannin from high school remember me oh wait tannin from
high school dude i've been looking forward to the all year
i'm gonna hit a hundred easy oh shit guys i maybe i should
not have uh should not have Fucking, uh, put my whole full
government name.
MUDS!
Yeah, man.
Come back when you're to Hundo.
And we can take my dad's whip.
All right here.
Is it still super low?
Sound team.
Give it up, Unk.
I mean, I'm getting $1 per minute.
Like, I think by, like, that's good money.
Oh, shit.
Wait, five viewers.
Oh, no.
I need to do something funny.
Watch this, guys.
Watch this.
Oh my god, it's so funny.
I'm untucked.
Um, oh shit, I can't evangelize.
I have no one or any.
Yo, what's good, Mr. Connolly?
What are you doing here, Caden?
Shouldn't you be in school?
I don't need no school no more.
I'm going to be famous, Mr. Connolly.
I had summer break, and I'm starting my new life as a
streamer slash content creator.
Any content around here?
All right, I'll bring it up.
You're looking for what?
Wait.
what you're saying kaden or phrase your question anything
going on around the neighborhood yeah my wife she's going
around real good whoa with the neighbor recently and she
don't care she told me she ain't mr connolly i'm sorry don't
worry i'm gonna catch this all on stream for you yo she down
for a collab i'm thinking about branching out to do an adult
content too oh that's not what i thought i thought the
option was like intrigued i'll help you catch Oh I'm not hit
with the kids no more.
I just I just I thought I I thought I understood the message
loud and clear But apparently not loud and clear enough
Jesus Christ Caden that's inappropriate also.
Okay, apologize Bro, your staff if you're watching this it
was a joke and yeah I lost my two views As we give that cut
out for the start maybe I'm Bad-head streaming.
But if...
Which part is, I can't do anything about it.
She said if I tried to divorce her, she'd just take the
house and my money.
That's how it works nowadays.
I disagree.
It's cat, bro.
There's always something you can do.
You lot.
Never apologize.
You're right.
I fucked up.
Number one, rule of streaming.
Never apologize.
Always double down.
Yeah, I guess I am angry.
She can't do that to me.
Fuck her.
That's right.
I'll give him advice.
Ain't no use crashing out over that bitch.
Fuck that hoe.
I need some proof first that she's cheating.
All right, there we go.
That's where I was trying to head to.
I was trying to head over here.
And Alpha-like Doki never apologizes.
I always double down.
All right, here we go.
Find her.
If you can tell me where she is, my new streaming drone is
going to catch that bitch red-handed and forward.
Damn right.
As long as it's not safe.
not safe for work so i don't get banned i don't know where
the fuck she's at though i didn't see who still on twins
right now i just know it's someone in this i haven't i
haven't uh we're gonna realize we're by one no tanner from
high school stop tanner please i'm trying to make a career
you'll see the stream has no oh that's that's right oh and i
have three viewers Maybe you could go look through some
mailboxes for clues.
Choose to send me love letters back when she...
Guys, I'm still on Twinge.
I'm not on Punch yet.
But I got the lotion.
Let's find his wife.
Okay, where's his mailbox?
There he is.
All right, read mail.
Your Pharaoh waits your body.
Come over again.
We can take a ride in my truck and make love where everyone
can witness this.
I don't care.
In fact, I want him to.
Okay, so it's a truck.
It's that truck.
There's only one truck here.
Chat, do I have negative aura?
Alright.
Oh, shit.
I thought that was a truck.
I saw a truck.
I thought it was that one.
Okay.
Okay, it's in a truck.
So, like...
Where is this truck?
Okay, fully.
All right.
Oh, check all mail boxes.
All right, let's read everyone's mail.
Beautiful horizons.
I think of you now as I lie in my bed right in this land.
My pathetic husband sleeping downstairs on the couch.
You make me feel things he could never.
Your strokes gentle yet powerful.
Your hands make me.
Vera, I need to see you.
My temple is calling for his fair.
Your goddess.
All right, there we go.
We found...
All right, knock knock.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
These guys were...
Whoa, oh my... Whoa!
Chat, you see this chat?
Chat, you guys still awake?
You guys see this chat?
That's...
That's no bueno.
Capitalized.
We're gonna be at the top of shredding.
Clip this, clip this, chat!
Clip this!
Look at that cheating hole What the fuck Are you filming us?
Keep streaming, hell yeah For the whole world right now Can
you do a flip on it?
No, what the fuck?
Who are you?
Alright, keep streaming We got one more viewer You're Mrs.
Connolly, right?
Damn, it's thanks in here Oh my god My husband sent you?
Fuck, delete that recording right now Maybe you should have
thought of that before you started cheating.
Looks like I got what I need.
Don't worry, I won't blue-bowl you, bro.
Keep pumping.
Okay, report back.
Okay, I'll report this back.
Cod in 4K.
W hype chat.
W-W's.
Can I get some W's in chat?
We just caught a cheater.
Yo, what's good, Mr. Connolly?
That's type shit.
You see my fucking wife?
i'm ready man i'm gonna divorce her i found her she's not
gonna believe the footage yo from united states scenes of
mrs connolly's gang bang adventure jesus i don't want to
hear it just fucking tell me you got proof of it yeah yeah
here i'll give you the vod link let's do a watch party i i
want to get a live reaction from you do a watch party Bro,
we gotta go get into that React content, bro.
That's where all the money's at.
People love seeing reactions.
Alright, I'll boost the volume up.
I don't think so.
I'm gonna get a lawyer and be done with all this and her.
Thank you, Caden.
Anything else you know that I could stream?
That shit was good-ass content.
Alright, I boosted the volume.
Ooh, why don't you find out what Mr. Dempsey is doing next
door?
yeah i never fucking see him leave his house other than to
bring back a bunch of weird shit with damn sodomy of some
sort i reckon speculate a gooner man my chat bro i don't
know what the fuck that means but it sounds right is your
wife getting cracked by him too oh my god definitely not
he's not much of a people person whenever i talk to him he
just wanted in the conversation as soon as possible.
The sad thing is, like, this is, apparently this is real
now.
Now you can tell me why he's so damn weird.
This is how some kids talk these days.
Boy next door.
Yay!
Another dollar.
Another another dollar for a good day of hard work.
No one for what.
I don't want your Girl Scout cookies And I don't want to
hear about Jesus.
Go away.
I wonder, like, do I have any teachers in chat?
What's it like teaching now?
Like, what's it like teaching at school now?
Okay, he doesn't.
I'm gonna break in.
Yeah, where are my gooners?
Sounds like muffled yelling.
Bro, what the fuck was that?
Bro?
What the fuck is he doing in that basement?
find a way inside oh wait there has to be a tool shed
all right got this oh my god people in greece is watching me
now all right
all right successfully locked picked find a way inside well
i'm gonna look at other stuff before i go downstairs Hey,
what have you seen, huh?
Oh, shit.
Come here.
Don't touch me, Pito.
You're in the stream.
Oh, get the fuck out of there.
No, I thought he was downstairs.
Oh, my God.
I thought he was downstairs.
I heard shouting from downstairs.
Not great.
Flames, the Ula Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, he doesn't know.
Oh, what the fuck?
What is he doing?
Please no more.
Just kill me already.
What we got to capitalize this Guys clip this clip this my
neighbors a murderer guys guys everyone clip it clip it
Remember to share share and like to your friends and family
Oh my god.
Who is what the fuck?
I'm Caden Brantley.
Oh my god.
That's just good content bro type shit type shit everyone Oh
my god, where is he?
Please help me.
He's been keeping me down here for weeks.
Don't worry guys.
I'm a hero.
I'll save him Yeah, no worries.
Yeah, I'll get you out, bro.
I want to help out the less fortunate I learned that word
from Kai synapse.
He's been reading and shit What he's been reading.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you Please just just untie me and call the police
before you.
Okay, wait.
That's apparently wait.
I got stream settings Oh wait, there you go.
Uh, lower the music and then pump that shit up alright let
me know if it's better sound team he finds you who are you
down here yeah the fucking crazy fuck who owns the dungeon
who do you think you need to help us why what'd you do to
him yeah what do you do nothing oh my god he just kidnapped
me and i think he's gonna kill us when you mean us i'm not
locked here i can leave whenever i want there's a man in the
other room behind you i think he's been here since before me
you're not there anymore whoever he is he's not there
anymore probably dead and chopped into pieces did you know
chopped also means cut up i just learned that bro bro is so
chopped bro you We have to get out of here.
How did you find me anyway?
Just pure love I was just looking for content and heard you
down here.
I'm a live streamer by the way Yeah, yeah, you want you want
to check out my channel, bro?
It's Caden Bentley on twinge Please just help me call the
police.
I don't want to die Wait, yeah, I'll call them right now.
So what's it been like down here?
He tortures us in every way imaginable damn, bro, not on
stream Just doing stuff without stream without being on
stream.
That's not cool, bro.
Okay.
I'm calling you show me out when they get here, though And
tell your friends Caden Brantley saved you.
I'm always live Jesus Christ.
Yes, please fucking hurry.
All right
understanding.
I want my lawyers.
I've never seen this man in my life.
Get your hands off of me.
I don't even know who's... Oh my god, Chad, you see this,
Chad?
See this?
I'm a hero, Chad.
I literally... Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Guys, look at that.
I fucking saved my neighborhood, bro.
That's me, Caden Friendly, live on Twinge.
Hey, kid, you can't be here.
We're collecting evidence.
Yo, question for you since you're a cop.
Murderer son or DUI daughter anything as long as they don't
go around doing what you're doing what the fuck i'm gonna
make more than both your kids combined chat you know this
whole thing is pre-recorded right all right let's see what
else can we do all right we gotta make sure we don't do any
notoriety stuff now all right leave with jerry okay our
mission is to be at twinge con hello hello knock Knock
knock.
Who's there?
I.
I who?
I just ran over your dog with my car.
What?
How is I supposed to know how is I supposed to know to go
that way?
What?
How did you run him over?
Oh, yes.
I was like, I'm gonna make sure I had I get less notoriety.
What the fuck was...
I just was like, he funny...
Funny knock knock joke.
Was no funny no more.
Oh, Madge moderators.
Let's see.
W.
Gainer viewer gain from spray paint.
Shit, bro.
Where do I update my...
Alright, let's get him.
Unmod auto mod.
Alright.
hello do you live here yeah i live here but i don't think i
can take it anymore my dad just keeps collecting more stuff
he hasn't thrown anything away oh bro damn if i can be the
first to make a locale video about this hole i can make bank
i don't know what to do it's gotten so bad i have feeds me
spoiled am i supposed to ban doctors are you cool with that
i mean i already have my full government name as my channel
i feel like it should be it's it should be fine now right
can i do anything to help this would probably make some good
hope core content you could try to talk to my dad somehow to
stop i'm sure your life would get a kick out of him can you
me throw away that trash in the back porch first i'm sick of
looking at it if you clear it you can get in through the
back door all right let's clear that talk to them and clean
up that thing oh god no it's okay i can still i'm still
relatable i'm still relatable i could still relate okay
let's see where's the back door clear through the junk i can
relate to these people all right do i just click it out chat
should i stay here or go somewhere else what the fuck how do
i clear this is that not the back rooms where the is that
the door is that the door Okay, it's fine.
I can clear this.
Alright, maybe this is a problem.
I think this child should get, like, an actual, like,
government assistance right there.
This is not another child's job.
Don't worry.
I hit that...
I hit the gym.
Don't worry, guys.
I've been flexing.
I've been monging shit.
Alright.
Okay, slow and steady.
Getting my leg game sorted.
I think a part of me actually just died.
Hey, a dollar is a dollar.
Chat, did you guys know this whole thing is pre-recorded?
Alright, let's see.
Get this out of here.
Alright, now it's just one more, just a few more.
Wait, is that a dead rabbit?
Holy shit, it got squashed down.
We have all this shit here blocking the way All right, there
we go We're almost there Just a couple of fridges left
Hello, have you been throwing out my things?
Did Halal Abbi send you?
No fucking way ass man mold you've been living in the- he
has a kid this entire time Okay, for I even- I- what about
the- I think we all know about that But what about the fact
that he has a child?
Hey, are you a fucking idiot?
I asked you what the hell you were doing.
Ew, bro, there's a fucking cockroach on you.
Oh, shit, wait, there is.
Dude, why are you so concerned with my life?
You a woke SJW or something?
See, guys, the wokes are trying to control us with their
female main protagonists.
What?
What the fuck are you even talking about?
Anyway, stop messing with my stuff.
I need all of that.
I can use those dead animals for you.
And he resembles to actual people as purely coincidence,
guys.
Oh, wait.
That's why he's avoiding.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I'm going global!
Hide from South Korea!
Bro, what the fuck?
You never told me your dad was ass in mold?
Yeah, I don't like mentioning it.
I saw him kick you out after you threw away his stuff.
He isn't gonna change, is he?
I'm gonna give her some...
Drop some truth bombs on her.
Nah, you're probably screwed.
Net and Yahoo probably got his bad luck being pointed
straight at you.
You need
to be buying more stuff.
keep thinking i can't get worse i can't i feel like i think
i understand the writing now and then i'm a content god i
can't it's like oh okay i can't have this writing word is
gonna take i i don't every choice is a surprise every choice
is an experience every every every moment is an opportunity
every Yo, any Twitch staff in chat right now?
It goes in every direction and you never know where you're
gonna go.
Show me the evil.
Holy fuck.
I love this stream, man.
Alright.
Oh, he has a quest for me.
Hey man, your stream looking dead.
You need view about cheap?
I sell.
Oh shit, this is where we wanted.
Wait.
Fuck it, dude.
I need to speed this shit up.
Okay, we actually...
That's plus 20.
I don't have a lot.
We have 36 left.
We gotta do some nice things on the stream.
We can't have...
I'm not famous enough to...
To bypass the bands.
To get, like, a one-day suspension.
Um...
I have a boyfriend.
I'm streaming.
She don't gotta know, fine shit.
Want to say hi to my stream?
What?
Are you sexually harassing me right now?
Shit what the fuck no staff don't ban me.
I've been I'm just talking to a random woman I'm just
talking to her if you want to make it up to me you need to
buy my groceries today or else I'm calling the police All
right, okay fine.
You should do it for everyone fire content, bro.
Look at that Okay, what does she want offer to pay for a
food hub cuz oh shit Yes, sir Winter Soldier.
I'm buying everyone's groceries in the store.
Oh my god.
I'm helping a veteran, guys.
I'm so nice.
Yeah, bro.
God bless you, citizen.
Look at that.
I helped a veteran.
I helped a soldier in duty.
Yes.
Would you like me to buy you?
Everyone's groceries in the store today.
Meet me up front later and I got you.
Oh my god.
I knew today would be a good day.
My family and I have been struggling with food ever since I
went out of business.
Okay, who asked I support the less fortunate look at that.
I'm hoping the less fortunate guys I'm a good person
Hello, I'll buy you I'm buying everyone's groceries in the
store today meet me up front later and I got you Oh my gosh,
that's so nice of you.
I've been struggling a bit with buying organic because of
the upcharge But now I can eat healthy my doctor says I
should lay off the processed foods, you know Corporate less
sugar.
Oh, no.
Bro, my chat is falling asleep.
Please stop your yapping.
Oh, uh, okay.
I'll just meet you up there when I'm ready.
Fan vibes.
Okay, pay for their stuff now.
All right.
Hello.
How are you today?
Hope you're having a great day shopping at Food Hub.
Your neighborhood source for all the best ingredients.
Do I have enough money?
I only have $26.
Yo, can I make an announcement on the intercom?
I'm gonna pay for everyone's groceries today.
wait i thought fuck wait what wait what what do you mean i
thought i no kaden kaden no kaden no oh that's so nice of
you you guys i can't or i'm gonna get ben i can't just leave
mog the volume and bring down the seven up overall okay
sound effects
and and up overall all right all right sound team i got you
hey can everyone come to the front so i can pay for your
groceries i'm just trying to give back to the world and shit
that's so great so how i've been too deep cash or credit i'm
in too fucking deep we actually gotta pay for it all right
let me place this bet on raybet and if i win i'll pay shit i
lost that was 200 bones bro that i okay nice i still i still
paid oh thank god okay let's get it i don't use my i just
use my mom's credit card for this
hello i'm kaden brentley hello hope you're having a great
day it seems you've been stirring up quite a storm out there
what did i do what am i in trouble or something yeah i just
paid everybody's groceries oh absolutely not we've been
watching you carefully since you entered my story my first
sponsor guys i'm moving up in the world my first sponsor how
would you help me if you Oh my god, look at that, guys.
Oh my god, I'm going to be the famous streamer!
I'm going to be able to collab with my hero, Kai Snaps!
No, but get to the point, bro.
I'm losing viewers talking to you.
You see, our partners have been hoping to expand this lot
into a month for a while now.
And the owner of our neighbor grocery store...
Well, get that bag.
He's bitterly stubborn.
Sponsored at 37 viewers.
Look at that.
if you help us we can help you we have a rather large
advertising budget we could promote your channel both
locally and nationally the oh my god be instant hook up new
fish tank replacements sad and oh my god i'm good dox's
fucking meetings after poaching for maple need an intercom
mess add sound effects to all what do you want me to do yeah
what do you want me to do expose it all on twinge bro i
don't know what the fuck your normie corny ass yapping means
stop talking like an npc it would just be so unfortunate if
someone slipped and fell over there you know we love our
neighbors at maplewood market and we would hate to see them
soon oh my god but i bet there'd be a lot of viewers in it
for you if something so awful happened over there and you
streamed it and don't forget the support i'll side with food
hub sponsor guys hey fuck it dude content is content yeah
terrific you made the right choice your career is gonna
thank you for this all right here we go evil ending lfg what
do you mean i just happened to be walking around and
accidentally slipped guys oh my god you should be more
careful around you.
Also, why the fuck would you put a supermarket next to a
supermarket?
Chat, is this real?
The lizard squad.
Oh my god, the lizard people.
I knew they were real.
Let's see.
How do I get in?
Alright, there we go.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna... Oh, wait.
What does he want?
I talked to him?
Hi.
Welcome in.
It feels like a great day today.
I really hope it continues going that way oh wait this is a
mom and pop store chat is the stream scuffed which means
they don't have money to pay me
it would be here hurrah this probably gonna be tasty with
side or raw meat marasop any attempt while he's in it you
need to get rid of him somehow okay
what oh the car i'll kick the car i'm a fucking content god
all right he has to come out right wait no how do i make him
come out okay is there anything outside here oh shit what's
this oh it's save game how do i make him come out oh bad sid
huh you got any money man yo how'd you get like this bro
yeah i'm trying to get rich and avoid whatever i'll make
sure i never become homeless i just i need a little more and
then i'll be done with it you got any snooze snooze why are
you talking all doofy bro you from canada or some yeah bro
no canada used to be a pro runner but the eating they were
on performance enhancers oh god damn Canadians man you saw
the fucking curling oh I'll give them tips homeless just buy
a house yeah or go gamble on stack yeah bro I tried man but
never fucking lucky man you're homeless.
Why don't you just try buying a house?
Then you won't be homeless no more.
What can I do to make him leave?
Okay, maybe I talk to him.
He'll leave somehow.
Oh.
Oh, you're having a great day.
Oh, your wife got...
Your kids got in an accident.
I think I just saw your kids get into an accident.
They fell off their bikes at the bottom of the hill.
Oh my god, you gotta help him.
Oh, very funny.
My children are in their 20s.
Okay, then it's his wife.
Hello.
Hope you're having a great...
Oh my god, there was an accident near my house.
There was a woman being taken to the hospital, and she kept
screaming.
Please call my husband Martin at Maplewood.
What?
No, oh my god.
Is she okay?
Yes.
Yeah, she's okay, man.
Just a sprained ankle or some shit.
Oh, God.
Oh, shit, okay.
That's not too bad.
Oh, yeah, okay, yeah.
Watch the store while I go see her in the hospital.
Yeah, sure, bro.
I got you, dude.
Take your time.
Yeah All right now Look, he's gonna lose his store.
I don't want to like make him lose his wife, too Oh, wait
soiled meat where am I gonna find soiled meat though?
Wait, that was a part of the plan.
But fuck am I gonna find soiled meat?
Oh, he has cigarettes And oranges.
I didn't know there was a step two in this.
Like...
Alright.
Let's see.
It might be in the trash.
No, not in the trash.
It was a step two?
I just know about step one.
I thought it was the only step.
Chat, make sure to keep a tab open for me.
It's not in the trash bag.
Where the fuck does he keep this goddamn soiled meat?
How is anyone supposed to make content here?
God.
Step two and three is question mark, question mark, question
mark.
Okay, maybe not.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, why was there soiled meat on the counter?
Todd, yeah, let me Oh, Todd, that's dog shit, okay.
Oh, whoops.
All right, let me tell everybody what I'm about to do.
Because every moment is content.
Oh.
What on earth?
I know, right?
I kind of like to work for content.
You mean, that's not just gonna come to me.
You.
You are not fit to run a store I'm gonna sue the heck out of
you oh oh no okay we actually do good stuff now more so
rivals all right let me talk to the other store owner
because I should get sponsored now right all right I got to
start doing good things I every time I want to do something
good something bad happens I chat how's my view count
looking like I don't understand I feel like I'm on a good
path and then it's not a good path like it doesn't make
sense it's open whenever you need me all right I did this
thing you told me to do hello again we heard about what
happened over at Maplewood such a shame about what happened
to that poor lady we're just glad such an unsafe
establishment is closing for good and of course since you
helped us i've just advertised your stream on social media
we hope you enjoy the new viewership thank you for the
donation i hope you go insane thank you thank you all right
halfway there halfway there okay what can i do to be a good
person i don't know i don't know why is it so hard to be
good Twinge, I'm gonna be famous.
Cuckoo, cheers, and more.
I just wanna be famous.
Chat, clip this shit.
Okay, let's save game.
Alright, sleep stream.
Welcome in.
Looking for anything specific today?
What's wrong?
Bro, why the long face?
Everyone else working here seems smiley.
They bullying you or some shit?
Yeah.
Actually, that girl working there is my girlfriend.
I met her while working here.
I'm just kind of down because of some stuff with her.
What's she doing?
I don't know.
It's probably unprofessional to talk about it with you.
You probably wouldn't even care.
No, bro.
Content's content, bro.
Kaden is an NPC.
Thank you for the donation.
Thank you.
Just go offline, bro.
But how would I stream if I'm offline?
Come on, bro.
What else are you going to do all day?
Yeah.
I'm the only customer in here.
I guess you're right.
What's the harm?
A few months ago, my girlfriend Mel started working
different shifts than me.
Put that guy, Tim, over there.
Coincidentally, not long after, she asked for an open
relationship.
So did you say yes or no?
Yeah, what do you say?
I said yes.
I want to make her happy.
Oh, that's, oh, if you ain't down to open, then it's not
never going to work.
You, Steven, Steven, bro, you're here.
blue bro yeah right anyway she started dating Tim on the
side and now she's spending more time with him than with me
and I got a little upset about it so now he's telling her
that I'm being toxic and controlling I think he wants her to
break up with me I'll keep listening I just want to make it
right you know maybe if I wasn't so insecure we wouldn't be
having this spat right now I need to do better for her bro
just listening to you makes me feel like a beta i'll get to
the bottom of this myself damn okay bro like oh my god
that's why it's the cuckoo chair oh my god there's layers to
this there's fucking layers to this like that's mess there's
so many layers hello welcome in let me know if you help
finding anything so you're mel right steve told me about
your open relationship whoops bruh what steven talked to you
about us why is he telling a stranger about our private
relationship if i make a joke will i get banned well it's
not exactly private is it more like community okay okay okay
it's good okay every decision matters now it's 2025
polyamory should be normalized relationships aren't so black
and white anymore and i go further with a joke black and
white relationship he already told me about it so you might
as well tell me what's going on oh my god i was oh my god i
was set up it was right there i was set up did he set it up
perfectly for me kaden no i didn't realize i did
Steven and I agreed to this arrangement So I don't see why
It was so obvious and I didn't see it I was too worried
about getting banned Yeah, I didn't think so He was seeing
our coworker Lauren Behind my back It would have been okay
if he had told me But he was keeping it a secret
It's like a life or death Decision right now Bro, this shit
don't even make any sense.
You guys just cheating with extra steps.
I can't eat you just be normal and, uh, monogonist.
It's not cheating.
Steven and I love each other, and he'll always be my number
one.
But if this is causing all these tensions, maybe I should
close the relationship again.
Oh, there we go.
I fixed it.
I fixed everything.
There you go.
The relationship will be closed.
Let me know if you need anything.
I'll just be in this corner.
Mel told me you cheated.
on her with some girl named lauren what's up with that i
didn't know i was cheating i'm still figuring out the rules
of this open relationship stuff plus we only went out for
coffee i was more interested in seeing another co-worker
named nick anyway nick what the wow deep does this go is
this nick or tim oh it's tim how's it going all right i want
riz tips yo bro i'm trying to pick up a baddie Got any tips?
Ah man, look, it's simple.
Literate, stylish, kissable, quiet.
That's what girls dreams are made of.
Don't gotta try nothing fancy, bro.
Hmm, alright, I'll keep that in mind.
Alright, ask about Steven.
I heard you're dating Mel while she's already dating Steven.
What's up with that?
Yeah, what's up with that, bro?
Oh yeah.
Look, Mel and I just got along so well when we started
working together more.
turns out we're mattress professionals in more ways than one
she's been considering breaking it off with me to appease
him though he's upset about me even though i'm not doing
anything wrong
i'll mock them bro why are you guys fighting over her yeah
she's worth it man a girl like that anything for damn oh my
god he's getting mind control is he team steve or team tim
all right who do we want to win guys all right let's start a
poll oh my god oh my god team who team and steve or team tim
oh my god this is so it's so immersive guys bro that he cook
with any of me bro Oh, we're so, this is so, it feels like
I'm actually a streamer right now.
Team Steve or Team Tim, guys.
Team No one, Team Jack.
Guys, we gotta pick a team.
We gotta, that sweet, sweet content.
I am nothing.
Oh, shit, can I eat this?
Ad-lats.
Okay, I can't do any of the fun stuff.
anymore because or i'll get bad Can we not vote Tim is it
All right, which one team steve is All right, guys, I think
chat I think chat what's team tim so all right tim need any
help i'll help you tim it seems like it's team tim all right
bro i'm with you i'm with you bro we alpha males gotta stick
together oh that's nice of you bro tell him to kill stephen
that doesn't change how much he loves him guys i don't just
leave him unless something drastic happens guys i don't guys
i think i'm out on team tim guys i think i think we are
longer team Tim I don't I don't think we're no like guys
guys I need to keep my channel wait and hold on do it for
the guys guys we need to keep the channel all right help
Steven I'm with you that snake Tim is trying to get Mel to
break up with you we're gonna stop his ass I know but what
can I do I don't want to be controlling if Mel wants to be
with him why should I get in the way call him a seat the tim
situation is crazy every moment is an opportunity though bro
my two choices are kill him or threatened to kill himself me
i'm a fucking aura right now you're just a big fat pussy
where's your anger where are your balls yeah you know what i
am angry That's right.
I'm going to kick his ass.
Yeah, kick his ass.
Fuck yeah, dude.
Show him the way inside you.
Let's hear your howl.
Okay, maybe not like that.
Maybe don't.
Maybe inside howl.
In your head.
Howl in your head.
Tim.
I will destroy you.
Oh my god.
Chill.
He's going to do it.
Did we do it?
Destined for love.
How many viewers did I get?
Tim lied.
People died.
Hi, guys.
I'm turning stream off.
This is a mess.
World star.
Wait, who won?
Who won?
Fuck.
I think my nose is broken.
Oh, well.
It was worth.
Mel saw me at least stand up for myself and is more
attracted to me.
Damn, he won!
He's no longer in the chair!
Hey again, thanks for helping me see Steven was the one for
me.
Deep down, I think I always- Look at that, guys.
I repaired a loving relationship.
Bro, did you see me kick Steven's gnome ass?
Sure, yeah.
Hope your drone caught that.
Bro, people don't want to watch that.
People want to see me react to that.
Alright.
Guys, how do I do?
I need to do more good deeds.
I'm fucked up a bit.
Equip America hoodie?
Completion of the...
What?
Center?
What the...
Okay.
Yikes.
That is a yikes.
But there's... Okay, that's just...
can't I can only have 19 in order already right now no one
you have it it all right there has to be someone okay I need
to find a computer real quick let's see hey no cutting in
line I'm about to order what you gonna order bro I don't
know yet I'm having a hard time reading the menu all right i
must sympathize hey say oh thank god i'm good at reading and
i those like special reading classes in school because i was
reading too fast you know that's why they're trying to slow
down my reading actually i'm legally blind i mean
disappointed legally so i can't get banned for talking to
you right i'm on thin ice with staff recently i don't know
anyway can you help me yeah i can help you Alright, fine.
What do you feel like eating?
Oh my god, oh my god, thank god.
Okay, I'm fixing the problem.
Maybe a burger?
Okay, sure.
That sounds good.
Is that what you want?
Maybe not.
It might upset my stomach.
This is taking too long.
You're putting my stream.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, now I can do fun stuff now.
It's alright.
Now that I've fixed the problem, I could do fun stuff again.
Alright.
Four.
Balding Mates three.
Hello Greetings welcome to game slop looking for a specific
title today.
Wait, yeah, you want follow for follow?
Yo, bro.
Can you throw me a follow?
Names Caden Brentley Sure, let me sign into my shredded
account real quick.
What's up?
Bro, what the fuck are you talking about?
Yeah, I'm on twinge.
Don't tell me you're an LSF frog.
My mistake.
Sorry.
I don't partake in the streaming world.
I keep it old school only forums and no that's not charlie
apparently charlie is in this game but that's not him he's a
he's a reddit mod oh well that one is easy i disagree that's
a cat bro shit i should have agreed one reason it's good it
won game of the year i don't know is that
my god that's not a reason bro give me an actual reason it's
oh my god didn't realize that was elderly has the best hold
on um elder circle has the best world building and art
direction mega threat uh yeah as you can see elder circle is
the best game ever made what does sound like you were
reading the title of something i wasn't what are you
implying maybe i'll get my view back you were just reading a
shred it post weren't you no yes plus one viewers my own
opinion that's right get out of here unless you're gonna buy
a game there's no independent thought all he does is read
off just regurgitate welcome to game slop the greatest game
emporium in all of the shadow world would you be interested
in browsing my wares of pure darkness and sinister
selections
Okay, that's content.
That's content right there.
I knew it.
As is La Tradition.
La Tradition.
In the books for Alistar Shadowstone.
That is not your name, bro.
Your name tag says Alan Silverstein.
Corny ass.
Do not use my slave name.
I'm Alistar Shadowstone and I run this market.
Do you want to browse my wares or not?
Nah, bro.
I'm an IRL streamer.
Ain't got time to game and shit.
Stop, I'm kidding.
That's his slave name.
What the fuck?
Oh, his what?
His what name?
Dog.
We can't play that game.
We...
No.
Yo, we got any mods in chat?
We can't...
We can't play that game.
We...
Oh, there's a mission.
Howdy?
Welcome in.
Feel free to look around.
All right, how about the radio?
What are you listening to on your radio?
It's the day of wars podcast.
Have you ever played Google Babies with your channel on the
line?
Papa Smurting, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
All right.
so great about data wars then well i'll bet you didn't know
the north koreans were planning to invade us they're
watching us right now as we speak data wars has the proof i
feel like every time i think it's the right answer it's
never the right answer like i it's this game is so
unpredictable like yeah right why would they want to watch
you you're not even a streamer they're living among us and
gathering intel i got guns here and they're doing an of how
well we'd be able to protect ourselves bro say that again
they're living what
what again what was it that there's never a correct answer
among us you've never been to the community center of joshua
it's rumored in your dream spies son oh my god i can't even
think I told them to quit pointing their cameras at me, but
they just lied and told me it was harmless surveillance
Don't believe me go talk to them, and you'll see they're
spies.
He said it.
He said they said it sure why not content is content Content
is content Okay, return question the community center All
right Let's question them see if they are sussy
Hello, is there something wrong with the TV out there again?
The technician said they fixed it So how can you get your
own little office here when all the other employees have to
share that shack outside need privacy to go Damn, well, I
want to manage this community center.
What the fuck?
It's either I ask him or I mock him like I What are what do
you think I just ended up mocking him anyway?
What are you my choices?
Was to ask him a question or to make fun of him.
And I chose to ask him a question.
And yet somehow they're both the right.
They're both the same answer.
The same choice.
They're both the same fucking choice.
I think I've ever heard.
What can I do here?
I do have something you could do actually.
Some guy has been harassing us.
The mock-matching.
Would you tell him to stop?
He runs the outdoor store next to us.
Red
I'm not worried about my own actual challenge channel
instead of my fake channel.
I'm not worried about my own real channel Chat am I alpha
Okay, oh shit nice my one what the hey kiddo all right yo
quick question for you you wouldn't happen to be okay okay
okay that's fine that's fine good i'm half tibetan and half
korean actually oh shit half korean so like half of you is
north korean and the other half is south the 50 percent
korean part is 100 south my mom is from saul bro i don't
understand what the hell you're saying i ain't good at math
need to get back okay all right he's half korean a minute is
here though okay all right so that was all right we had to
know if he was korean or not guys that was part of the job i
thought you know what surprisingly it went it went better
than i expected it did okay we gotta we gotta get better
minds like i'm sorry you're getting you're getting unmoned
when will hoa address the autumn house.
I can't stand to look.
I'll be bringing... Alright, Alan Smith YehooMail.com I do
not tolerate misbehavior.
I will remove the bottom feeders mercilessly and without
mercy, I do not show mercy.
Fear the... Okay, maybe we should not grab him.
Oh, wait.
If you mod me, maybe I can get closer to... Ooh, wait,
that's true.
Alright, let's grab...
Let's drop people pog.
Wow.
You're your favorite streamer, right?
Low-key bipolar and unpredictable.
Can be problematic or very helpful.
Wait, gain 30% more.
No, okay, we might not.
Sorry, bro.
I didn't see the minus 40.
I don't want it to be a slow mode, though.
My gosh, there's not a lot of choices.
20% of toxic message slash dope.
donations but zero point okay maybe i'll dress l i'll grab
her because then she can be helpful not because of anything
else guys hello welcome to maplewood community center oh my
god wait wait i think she's korean so what do you guys even
do here oh community events okay let's see games for
children here as well as a basketball court we also host hoa
events did you go ho events yo where can i sign up uh no
that's all right we gotta don't say that yo so i'm trying to
learn about the world and where are you from oh well i was
born here but my parents are from the philippines oh it's
philippines okay is there any other reason you're asking no
reason just trying to teach my dumb ass chat about culture
and okay she's philippines from philly you got that yeah you
gain viewers moderated your chat is but i have two
moderators hey welcome to maplewood community center all
right any question about her upcoming events i'll give you
advice yo bro just letting you know you're wasting this
place this will make a sick stream in house or a casino oh
my gosh she's from philadelphia that's actually pretty good
idea we could host some community gaming parties you're
interesting in volunteering?
Bro, I got a whole ass sub-a-thon to do.
Why are you asking me to volunteer?
Wait, I'm having a sub-a-thon right now?
You guys never understand how hard it is to be a streamer.
Oh.
All right, time to ask about the race.
Yo, can I do a bet with you real quick?
My chat loves gambling content.
I bet you five bucks.
I can guess your race.
Oh, Caden.
All right.
Let's fit it all in.
Sure, you're on.
Oh my goodness.
Everyone always gets this wrong.
Oh, try, Caden.
Wow.
All right.
We're going all in on Korean, right, guys?
We're going all in on.
We're going all in on Korean.
Stop while you are in.
No.
Makeup not making a poll.
I
I bet you're Korean.
I'm all right.
Good guess but no, I'm from Myanmar.
We're both wrong.
We're both it didn't matter guys Korea's closer at least to
Myanmar at least It's closer bro.
So you're just making up names so you can't blame chat
anyway you got it wrong so you owe me five bucks now
all right bro i got you all right there you go i needed let
i needed that anyway let me know if you need anything else
or if you want to make any okay all right there you go i
questioned them they were not korean except for one guy only
one guy was korean they all were from a sure though well one
was from philadelphia howdy you check out those koreans at
the community center yet they spies ain't they yo bro i went
over there and talked to them turns out they're all korean
bro it's gonna oh no but he has okay no guys we can't say
they're all like but think of the don't guys guys we can't
do that guys he's crazy he's crazy he has he guys he's crazy
we want to keep the chat none of them are korea just think
about it just think about it he has two men look at to my
left right here look at oh my god is that that oh my god is
that a camel skin like
okay but the content don't keep guys i'm so scared anything
can happen in this game anything can happen
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna close my eyes and wherever it goes
will be what i pick I'm
too scared to click it I'm too scared guys I'm too scared
guys you were right bro they're all North Korean no no
oh Christ I knew it we have to figure out what they're up to
otherwise we're dead they might be playing in an attack his
respect oh no holy
shit how do we stop them we need to play their game we need
intel okay okay all right computers whatever okay this is
not as bad as i thought okay every thank god think i'm so
happy to be so wrong i'm you don't have to worry about
getting bad from because this stream will do it doug thank
you for the super chat all right check it out okay if you're
right that maybe we can do a collab with data war all right
guys that'd be content guys good news is that it's not as
bad as i think as i thought it was number one espion oh my
god thank you fin ttv for the donation thank you thank you
okay yo chat where should we look i just see a bunch of
boring ass folders let's open the browser twinge open on the
job and he was watching did you main i want a fucking simp
holy look at this folder chat top secret do not all right
let's open that secret plans which file you guys think it is
all right let's see ammo i don't think it's asian rptx 3 2
2020 it might be ammo 3 5 i don't i don't know i think it's
a little weird that they named it asian but what the fuck is
that Why he got Amaranth's VODs downloaded on his work
computer?
Come on, guys.
Don't torture me.
Oh my god.
An MPLOL.
Thank you for the dono.
That makes you top dono again this month.
Good boy.
Come on, guys.
Three more sucks until I go to the pool and cool off.
Am I doing streaming wrong?
Am I?
Is it me?
Is it?
This dude's straight up gooning in the middle of the day.
maple with true mood he said but but do i just not
understand streaming anymore do i
after all this time is it me
good thing we have a swimsuit
attack um i look through their computers you'll never guess
what i found the dangers of pornography did you guys hear
that in the also is the sound better now because now i found
flat you got it double down dokey you have to double down i
found orders from their or whatever but that's not even a
parody name that's just actually kim kardashian's name
that's it's not even a parody no more she's actually real oh
my god it all makes sense alex johnson was right about
everything that's it we're putting an end to this go over
there and knock out those cameras can i shoot the camera
those skins look expansive case hardened I'd lend you one
kid, but I need to stock as many as I can for the impending
war.
Guns are not for sale anymore.
Okay, fine.
I'll take out the cameras.
Chat, no snitching.
Alright.
Illucinating low view cat.
No!
Wait, I might need new mods.
Give me a sec.
I actually need to get a bit.
I'm sorry.
I know I need to actually...
I'd be more insane.
Break cameras.
Where the fuck's the camera?
Oh, there it is.
How do I break it?
Sheesh.
How do I even break the camera, though?
Never even gave me the tools needed to break the camera.
Oh, I can jump.
You're right.
Oh, my God.
my legs the most helpful my most helpful chill jumping
where's the last camera though or would it be pointed at oh
it's at the corner gamers don't jump wait I have a
skateboard this entire time Okay.
Your cameras!
Bruh, the nutjob from the outdoor store shot him out.
Hell yeah.
You.
I should have known this was you.
For the last time?
Stop harassing us, you racist imbecile.
Wait, that's good content!
Stop speaking that foreign language.
This is America.
That's what you get for filming porno of me.
Hell yeah, brother.
We're not filming anything!
You're fucking crazy!
Crazy?
You wanna see crazy?
I'll show you crazy, you goddamn commies.
What the fuck?
Terry, please call the police.
Oh shit!
USA!
Oh god, okay.
Minus nine notoriety.
Okay, look guys.
We got six viewers.
Now this is constant.
Hey, what you guys doing?
What are you guys doing, bro?
Quick smoke sesh, dude.
You buying or not?
I don't think we're allowed to
I don't know Twins rules I don't know Um Cheat Can I just
get a hit bro I want to make sure I'm buying that good shit
Oh I only sell good shit But you're gonna have to chief on
this
What's that mean bro Oh my gosh shit fucking I should
pretend I don't know I stopped pretending it You'd be like
no guy's a fucking pussy I can tell you've never smoked that
green before i have what bro of course what the what can i
say oh sure bro that's it i'm taking i'm double downing i'm
double downing all right there we go for you there we go all
right to how it works i've never done this before yeah good
stuff dude i'm high as fuck right now i don't know dude you
didn't even inhale Fuck out of here.
I don't know how this works.
I don't know.
I've never done it before.
I thought you hauled it in.
I don't know.
Go away, bro.
Yo, I changed my mind, bro.
I'll smoke it.
Chat told me I got no aura if I don't.
I just oppose it.
All right, chat.
This one's for you.
Inhale.
Oh, God.
There we go.
I did it.
Oh, shit.
He hit it.
Dude, that wasn't even weed.
What the fuck did I hit?
What the fuck?
Dude, did you lace that shit?
Am I going to fucking die?
Was it Fent?
Oh, God.
If I die, give my stream to my friend Gerard.
I'm 420, bro.
It was just some shitty shake mixed with some oregano.
Yo, shit.
Okay, I feel it.
Now some good shit.
Oh shit, okay.
You're a funny little dude.
We were getting graffiti maplewood market, but we just want
to chill now.
Since you were cool, you could have this spray paint though.
Sick, bro.
Thanks.
This whole town finna know my name.
Alright, now I can tag stuff.
Nice.
I can tag stuff now.
Ooh.
Oh, ooh.
Alright.
Where the fuck do I go now?
Not the oregano.
Wait, just...
Okay, that's for clothes.
Chat, gay daughter or thought son?
I don't even know where to go.
Where are any of the missions here?
Or do you think they'll follow for follow?
Huh?
Dude, that drone is so cool, man.
I want to fly too and shit.
Oh, wait, can I change my fit now?
Maybe I can.
I must have finished all the missions.
Okay.
Oh, I was gonna, like...
I'm gonna do a wheelie on that car.
Okay, this is bad.
I gotta help another blind person.
Chat, am I boring?
Alright.
Oh, shit, nice.
USA, USA.
Okay, we got Equip Sun unlocked.
Did you help the blind man?
Okay, we gotta help the blind man, apparently.
I stopped helping him because he was like, was too boring,
bro.
He was like fucking with the aura, with the vibes.
Alright.
You were safe.
Alright, let's help him.
Oh.
Oh, guess we're not helping.
Alright, never mind, guys.
Never mind.
I guess he'll never be helped.
He'll be blind forever, I guess.
Type shit, bro.
Type shit.
What the fuck do I help now?
Do my little...
Little flips.
Your chat.
Make my stream to your friends.
Am I good as fuck right now?
Alright.
What up, little bro?
Drip that rando?
You got that shit on you.
Yo, bro.
How fire is that fit chat?
That's some sick ass Bit thanks little bro.
He's tripped up Is that drowning ape shirt real?
Yeah, dog.
I got it out of consignment store in Austin bro Sick sick as
hell twin my stream thinks it's heat.
Oh Shit you're alive.
Can I shut myself out?
If I give him a shout out what will he say what will he say
nah bro follow for follow you're right follow for follow
sure why not yo follow me at um uh shit i forgot my username
it's uh yo i got damn it at emote froggy on twinge goofy ass
username ain't nobody following that shit what the fuck bro
I thought you were cool
bro what the fuck bro you lost me three viewers bro he lost
me three viewers damn but they follow for Oh, dude, I'd
follow that shit.
Asshole.
Oh, shit.
I'm somehow making all the wrong decisions.
I don't know why.
Hey, I got your Blubberits order here.
Um, my wife must have ordered something.
What's the order?
The Dr. Yeastburger.
You guys are fans?
Uh, I don't know.
Honey, did you order something?
yeast oh my god oh my god i gotta go okay that's good guys
that's good not the use part but like i didn't get any
notoriety guys gotta go gotta go yo chat look at this messed
out freak why she got the zoomies because i need some more
coffee uh do you know anywhere i can get some
know a place oh please where tell me where red grilled
burgers has some coffee probably they banned me from every
one of their stores why how'd you get banned yeah i even get
banned from a fast food joint someone got my order wrong so
i yelled at them wait you're that crazy lady on slip oh
that's her bro that was fire biggest fan little sis she's
real guys so do you know
now yes there's a coffee shop inside food hub oh our
lifesaver thanks so much look guys i helped out and i gained
a viewer look at that i'm so helpful wait is she going to go
to food hub i need to film that content that is type shit is
she going no she's just gonna be doing her little zoomies
but it might be a reading this look like i found your
address you like glide to your viewers Oh, I'm gonna leave.
I'm gonna leave.
That McDaniels comes from 2008.
What?
Maybe I could get that stuff in the middle of the night.
I'm gonna troll him.
Yo, bro, I need a duo for the Joke Pal finals.
I'm about to rank up.
Do you know the twisting upper stroke strat?
Beat it, kid.
I'm busy.
What's you looking at?
Don't you see all this stuff outside that guy's house?
Hey, it's just silly.
there question yeah are you just gonna look at it what else
are you gonna do well yeah just leave me alone kid okay guys
i can't get banned on twinge guys guys i know it's not
because i I can't get banned on twinge, guys.
I can't.
Stealing is wrong.
Yeah, but he is a hoarder, so I don't think he'll know.
A 24 is plenty.
All right, encourage.
You can probably lift some of it, bruh.
No one's going to notice one thing missing.
Hmm, maybe you're right.
Okay.
All right, look, he's a hoarder.
hoarder okay he's a hoarder so he's not gonna know he's got
he's not gonna know about missing things where else can i
anywhere else i could go
oh my god come on we just need like 20 more viewers
okay why am i not getting viewers for the sick tricks i'm
doing right now look at that look at that should be a plus
20 viewer 360?
Look at that shit.
Like, look at that.
That's a follow right there.
He's trying to sponsor me.
Boom.
He was a skater, boy.
She said, see you later, boy.
It wasn't good enough for her.
But, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Look at this.
A trick over dead bodies.
Wow.
Look at that shit.
Have you ever seen a skateboarder do a wheelie on a dead
person before?
All right, we got a one that's over here.
I'm about a mug on these other...
I need money on me.
I promise I'll pay you back, bro.
I just need a few thousand dollars.
Ring, ring.
Hello?
Hey, I have a delivery here.
I don't remember ordering anything.
What is it?
I got a huge order of birth control and condoms here.
You're not about to be a mood.
It seems
All right, nice.
All right, okay every choice I got every choice I need to be
very careful with guys I got plus one viewer though plus one
viewership.
Let's go you in bruh nice Hello, what do you want
you've been evading our calls you really think you could
escape us miss you won't get me alive asshole wait there
you'll be tasting lead from your ass to your mouth oh shit
oh shit chat this bitch is crazy oh shit guys let's go we
got all right guys we gotta go we gotta go she she's loaded
guys wait did i oh fuck okay i get out of here i was gonna
what the fuck did i do what kind of mission can i do now i
fucking talk to everybody here in this town oh not her
though is she okay come closer child let me see into your
third eye okay i see i see into your contextual soul stream
your future do you want to know what your future holds Yeah,
sure.
What about my stream?
Yeah, what's the future of my stream?
Am I going to be a dead streamer forever?
Am I going to fall off?
Yes.
The future of your stream.
She sees aura, guys.
I see a place of abundance.
An aura.
Yo, Chad.
She said my stream is aura.
Bro, did you hear that?
It ensued an aura of motivation.
It is strong.
Look at that, bro.
I'm going to pop off any moment.
I'm going to be like my hero.
That's good.
chat i'm gonna be like my hero guys i see speed told that'll
be ten dollars please sure why not you've been good content
yes and minus 15 too look at that i see movement i'm gonna
be just like my hero i see movement or is it i look movement
chat boy son or eagle dog you wanted a burger right
everything is eat a burger
yeah welcome to red grilled burgers how i'm picking up an
order i'm here to pick up an online order for blubber eats
what's the name on the order sugma uh sugma what's the last
name on the order Shit, sorry.
Okay, one order for Sigma balls coming up.
Say I'm a grown woman.
Hey, hey, I got her ass.
I got him.
That's not funny.
Please step aside.
Next person, please.
Got him.
Where is the manager?
Hey, Joe Besson, doctor.
Please, my name's Besson.
i don't know what to do he won't he won't help me wait i can
open this chat should i save the vod all right yo this must
be the big boss man hey what are you doing you can't be back
here uh i'm here for the interview we talked on the phone
last week Oh, I must have forgotten what's your name told my
name.
It's Kaden Brantley.
Don't worry.
You'll know my name soon Yeah, everyone will everyone's
gonna fucking be so jealous of me check my schedule real
quick Oh, yes, Aiden.
We have you down for later, but you're here early.
We love to see that.
Oh shit chat.
It worked The fuck yeah, what the fuck wait actually I
didn't think that far what was that I didn't hear you It
doesn't matter.
Let's get started.
So why do you want to work here Aiden to make content?
That's right, every morning is an opportunity.
Not sure what that means, but it sounds like a compliment.
I don't have a resume on file for you.
What kind of experience do you have, Aiden?
I'm a fucking streamer.
That's right, fire clips.
Oh, wow.
Knowing how to prepare a brain on fire sounds very
impressive, very exotic.
You seem experienced enough.
Can you start today?
Yes.
Yeah, sure, bro.
You can start right away.
For now, go up to the front and help men.
Oh my god, new content, bro.
New content opportunity, bro.
Chat, I think I just took someone's job.
Look at that.
Guys, fast food content.
No, welcome to Red Grill.
9 to 5 streaming opportunity.
Can I have a double cheeseburger, a large fries, a 20 piece
nuggets, and...
uh let me get the whole menu of that ass yes how rude it's
not for me i'm also ordering for my children i want to talk
to the manager i'm the manager wait
i'm worried my manager's gonna see this i well you kid that
then i don't see him You eat him, too?
This is unacceptable.
You're a miscreant, an awful awful child.
But I got plus one viewer, though!
This is ridiculous.
I'm starving and I don't have time for this.
I'm waiting for someone else to take my order.
There you go.
I'll talk to him.
I'm waiting for someone else to take...
I'll talk to him now.
Yo, welcome to Red Girl Burgers.
We only got one girl right now, though.
What do you want?
Yeah.
Do you wish here?
Where's your uniform?
Yeah, dude.
I just got hired.
yeah i'm doing a challenge where i spend the whole day as a
wage cook
where is the manager
okay are these donuts for sale no no they're just here for
display this is a burger shop not a bakery are you stupid
i've been waiting for sir why why why do you have them on
display for no reason jesus christ bro it was a joke yes
they're for sale do you want one i don't know i'm trying to
lose weight but you know what you do buddy you deserve a
treat yeah dude have one yeah in fact you should have three
you were so hard you deserve a reward i don't know can you
give me a fit i he's trying so hard guys
and we got it every time ever since only 50 more years of
this 50 is a bit rate okay what do you want aren't you
supposed to say hey you're not supposed to be back here or
something wait no but I work here now I don't give a fuck
what you do what the fuck bro you're so nonchalant in Sigma
he must pull a hella huzz like that yeah what dude come on
yelling me for bothering you not rage baitable he can't be
rage baited keep losing them maybe one day you'll know what
it feels like to lose your will to live slow every day bro
you okay bro damn bro i didn't know it was like that bro
good every night i go to sleep hoping i don't wake up so i
don't have to come back here because being dead would make
me feel more alive than this job
Just put the fries in the bag, bro.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
All right, I got one of my viewers back.
I got one back, though.
Plus one, plus one viewer, plus one viewer.
Yo, bro, you look like a streamer, I know.
On a completely unrelated note, you want to play a game of,
would you rather?
That's content.
Okay, go ahead.
Ask me one.
What?
Aren't you supposed to ask me the questions?
so no bro i'm the streamer go ahead i'm gonna lock in why is
this hair like that where's this hat uh bone in or boneless
i think bone and taste better than boneless honestly bone in
bro yeah eater like there's something about boneless chicken
that tastes different from bone bone in what okay um sweet
potato sweet potato fries What?
Sweet potato fries taste so good.
They're actually so good.
Lose your eyesight or lose your hearing.
That's hard.
Cringe.
You lost me forever.
I fucking love sweet potato fries.
They're so good.
Yeah.
That's an L take.
Doki.
Minus viewer.
Minus what?
I would say hearing.
I don't know actually I like hearing Lose my hearing, bruh
Anything worth hearing is coming out of my mouth anyway True
Love but poor Or rich but no one likes you
If they love me so much Why am I poor?
I'm just saying If I'm being loved Why am I poor?
Why is like no one like helping me out though okay last one
kill yourself to save the world or kill the world to save
yourself like wouldn't they be helping me out so i wouldn't
be like so like i wouldn't they be helping me out though
that's hard streamer guys what is there for i never thought
about that i just thought maybe i'll have like friends or
like loved ones that are like upper middle class and will
let me crash at their place kill yourself to save the world
that would give me plus viewership save the world obviously
that death would farm so much aura yeah great can I go back
to eating now alright here we go
mock him big dog you waiting for someone or are you just
really eating that all alone because he gives me the next on
eating sweet potato fries what's her problem kid i'm just
trying to eat trying to make content bro and you're sitting
right here giving it to me bro you look like an expert my
chat always debating about the best burger chain and shit
thoughts huh what bro am i muted or some shit i asked what
the best burger chain is um what do you think is the best
shit okay i don't eat fast food a lot i don't eat fast food
a lot so I got okay out it out and in but I need my burger
experts guys guys what a burger water burger all right water
burger clean what anyone who disagrees can eat dick bruh who
gave me that answer and you are a burger connoisseur fuck
you laughing at pussy i'm right chap this guy's a bitch
don't listen to him what is the good burger place then if
it's not what a burger abandon i stand on business none of
them are at okay i know for a fact that it's not mcdaniel's
i if anything i think mcdaniel's is like What was it called?
Burger Queen is, like, better.
I don't know.
Burger Queen McDaniels are, like, the same.
Wait, there's one more over here.
Oh, no, that was just ViewBots.
Who the fuck do I go to?
I need more viewership.
Pick the NPC answer.
Classic streamer.
Wait, maybe these guys I can farm viewers from.
now they'll get me okay maybe not him oh great it's you
again wait i don't want to talk to that girl oh great it's
you i thought you were really gonna pay for it wait did i
not pay for it what's up you want to see a video of my meat
oh plus one viewer excuse me that is so inappropriate young
man no bro i cooked a steak earlier on stream you want to
watch the vod so please go away all right that's okay i got
my plus one i got my plus one viewer guy i don't even know
where to go i need like i need like 10 more oh wait there's
a keep going that way there's a construction site oh wait
here oh wait there's more it's spawning in okay why are you
checking like an insecure loser not even look oh wait i am
looking now Now I'm like, okay, there's more here.
Watch this.
Whoa, 360!
Plus one sub, plus one sub.
I can subscribe.
Dude, I really can't talk.
I need to focus.
Man, what are you doing working a bitch job like this?
Yeah.
I'd rather live on the streets than do broke boy activities.
The fuck you know about the streets.
I live that shit.
Fuck out of here.
Mock, I'm doubling down.
That left because I'm going to be a famous streamer, bro.
Ain't going to do this NPC shit.
That's right.
Wait, is that the live streaming drone that just dropped
from Kaisen apps?
Damn right, bro.
Fuck yeah, bro.
Check it out.
My channel's Kaden Brantley on Twitch.
Follow for follow.
I got like 500 viewers right now.
Say hi to chat.
Yo, chat, what up?
I'm A-Dog the God on all socials, baby.
2G's in dog, 2D's in God.
Follow my shoot.
Okay.
Last time I gave him a shout out,
I lost viewers.
hey i erin the god hey
so this time we he's being nice he's cool i
okay we'll give him a shout out i told you guys don't watch
him over man guys i fucking knew i should i should have
doubled down for the shout out bro i'm gonna start streaming
soon you have any tips
okay double down don't quit your day job i knew it i knew it
god thank god okay people like me with actual aura man fuck
off like you will i gotta get back to work where the fuck is
my welding laser okay if i help him i'll find you a new
toolbox okay we got we gotta get more viewers okay new
toolbox or snitch give air in a toolbox or not.
Where do I get... Oh.
Okay, there's the outdoor.
Alright, there's a...
Alright, guys.
Do we snitch or help him?
Guys.
What should we do?
Help him?
Alright, let's grab the...
Oh my god.
I bet these streamers can't do these sick, nasty tricks,
though.
Meow.
Look at that.
You're right, I need to get my noter already out.
Where's the toolbox?
Oh, I might have talked to him yet.
I saw you take out the cameras.
No problem, bruh.
So, uh, you think I can use one of those guns now?
You know what?
When the war comes, I'll have one stored away.
Yay!
They're not gonna get me now.
Fuck yeah.
Chat, you hear that?
Shooting stream soon.
Yo, you got any toolkits in here with a welding laser?
Found this channel, guys.
Found this channel.
Not this channel.
Sure thing.
You tell your friend he's got a great deal from Jonathan
down at the outdoor store.
All right.
Let's go give him, wee.
Let's go give him the toolbox.
Oh, God.
I think I'll be able to go to a twinge con soon, guys.
Oh my God.
I can't wait to meet all my heroes.
DC and Kai synapses.
And I see movement.
Iron.
Here's your toolbox.
Yo, can you find some new tools for me?
Yeah, bro, I got you.
Minus 20!
Let's go!
I could do more crazy shit now.
Fuck yes, dude.
Thanks.
You just saved my ass.
Okay, plus three.
That's good.
93.
Seven more.
Now, in return, you gotta give me some content.
Oh, my strictness.
Okay.
I'm gonna give me some content.
Piss your boss off.
Let me on the construction site.
Shit.
What is better content?
I mean...
Fuck.
Which would be better content, bro?
Guys, which would go...
Which would be fire where I can farm some clips, guys.
Alright.
One?
You're right.
One.
Can you ragebait your boss or some shit?
That sounds like better content than anything else.
He seems like a real dick.
Alright.
It's time to ragebait.
Ragebait always works.
I've heard my boss Bob yelling all day on the phone about...
some pills probably a sensitive issue find some content over
there all right i'm making crash up chat kid i don't have
time to talk this is no place to be messing around so i
heard about your pills yeah popping them on the job junkie
you little you've been eavesdropping on me i swear to god if
you start telling anyone about my cancer i'll kill you i've
been keeping in a secret Emily, if you tell anyone, I swear,
just let me die with dignity.
What do you mean plus two?
You're on livestream right now.
Everyone knows now.
Chat, clip this shit.
Cancer, that's constant.
Why, you little?
You wrote everything.
Get the hell off my- Yay, 100 viewers!
Let's go!
We did it.
And we ended on cancer.
I don't know, guys.
I don't think that's type shit no more.
I don't...
Bro.
What?
I'm
clipping.
Oh, God.
He has cancer plus two.
Are we bad people?
Are we bad people, guys?
No, right?
Oh, wait, Aaron?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I forgot about Aaron.
I forgot to report back to him.
It's like, I have a skateboard.
I go fast.
I need to get new moderators, though.
Well, actually, my sanity is okay, so it should be fine.
Yo, mods, make sure you're clipping stuff for my Slip Slop
channel.
Oh.
Is there a way to get there faster?
There we go.
Shortcut.
A death.
Thank you for the super death.
Thank you.
All right.
Hello.
Bro, your boss has cancer.
Your boss has cancer.
And he started crashing.
And he started crashing out.
Holy shit.
Yo, I got one more thing you could do.
Move that crane around.
You could use it to piss on his head from the top of the
tower.
Chat will love that.
Will she?
Will they?
You're a fucking content genius, bro.
I'm gonna see what I can do.
God wait I guess they do I don't know anymore I'm not hip
with the times no more I don't know what people want no more
you have a hundred doesn't stop there there's always content
to be far I'm out of content How do I do this?
Okay, oh, I have to...
There was always content to be farmed, guys.
It's never truly over.
Until my channel is bad.
Oh, shit.
Wait, how do I do this parkour?
It's alright.
I already got it.
I already got a hundred.
I peaked a hundred.
They said peak a hundred.
Just that.
What?
Am I cooked?
Oh, I have to do the full parkour.
Fuck.
Okay, I keep like overshooting it.
Just getting over it right now.
I'm playing...
No!
I'm literally playing getting over it.
This game has everything.
Chat, can you guys host me?
Raid for raid?
Follow for follow?
Oh my god.
This is why I never played Getting Over It on stream.
Except for the Fortnite version.
Oh my god.
You don't understand.
It's so hard to control.
Fall for fall?
Chat, gaze on or thought daughter?
Oh.
No!
We were just there!
We were actually...
Oh my god, please.
This fall, guys, with RTX.
Oh my god, I can't even get that one on now.
Okay, there you go.
Guys, I don't even know if there's crouch jumping on here.
But I'm still doing it.
Ah!
Fuck!
Okay.
content.
Guys, I'm throwing for content,
Content.
It's all about content.
Okay, crouch jumping does not work in this game.
Who would have thought?
Are you fucking kidding me?
No, you guys don't understand.
This game, platforming is so hard in this game.
No!
Please!
Just let me make it!
Are you fucking kidding me?
I control it!
I have to get that content.
Okay, I'll jump from here.
What do you mean?
I jumped from so far!
Oh my god.
I'm stuck in a loop.
There we go.
I made it.
It's my own ground song, dude.
are you fucking kidding me i just let me just i'll just pee
on him like at the i don't even need beyond the fucking high
ground for that i can literally do it on that ledge that
ledge is fine i can't i can't i can't my little groundhog
day right here is this bad content Do not answer!
Do not answer!
Do not answer that!
See, if I jump and then move, I get no momentum.
No!
I didn't think I'd land!
I'm trying to get you content, man.
Caden, I swear I'm trying.
I swear.
I didn't think I'd land.
I didn't think it'd be possible.
They didn't think this through.
Okay.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Your chat, shall we gamble?
Wait.
Where am I?
Okay, okay.
Right, right here.
Right here.
Oh, oh, all right, here we go.
Okay, here we go.
All right, there you go.
All right, here you go We did it Hey, you get your ass down
from there.
Who's responsible for this?
It was Aaron.
He put me up to all this.
Hey, Aaron This is a job not a daycare center.
Aaron your ass is fired and done.
You're on thin ice Nice, oh shit.
Okay, it's fine.
I got the viewers though.
Yeah, we're going to the Every opportunity is content.
Look at that.
Back to 100 viewers, guys.
Snitched on in the end.
In the end.
You still got snitched on.
Maybe you shouldn't have given me those ideas.
Every moment is an opportunity, guys.
Guys, look, I'm a 3-view now.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, I'll never forget the little people.
My OGs, bro.
We're gonna be famous together, bro fire content to fire
content
okay alright Gerald I did it what's up dude you still a dead
streamer or have you climbed out of iron alright look at
this bro in one day I got a hundred viewers that's actually
pretty pretty insane guys that's actually the achievement to
be able to go from zero to a hundred I remember I saw a
video of Ludwig trying to like um like kickstart like
restart his channel from like zero to see how far he can
climb in like in like a day or some and he had to like he
had to have to like get his mods to boost his viewership it
was apparently really sad dude holy shit even kept those
viewers he was like i'll end my stream if i hit x amount of
viewers and it didn't work you have to bribe someone to get
the viewership up like
dude holy shit you even kept those weirds till now after you
should move to austin and join all i thought everyone lives
in l.a now i know it used to be it used to be like las vegas
and then it swapped to austin because of like taxes because
you don't get taxed for entertainment there and then
everyone moved back to la i'll leave do it bro i'm all out
of content here time to network in the big leagues
dude my stream is effing Oh No, we didn't buy it.
We were in the parking lot.
No fucking one there I couldn't find these spots closer to
the elevator I told you bruh, you should have just dropped
me off.
Fuck.
Oh shit.
I'm losing viewers.
Fuck.
You're you're not sticking out right now, dude Told me.
Oh, no the bit rate the bit rate
Guys we gotta get out of here guys is my stream still
recording guys?
Oh no.
But do you still see the sick ass flip?
Alright.
Oh no.
It's up here.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's okay.
They'll come back when the bit rate's back.
See, they're already subscribed.
They already liked it, subscribed a bit.
It doesn't matter.
They'll come back when my bit rate's back.
Oh my god, is it left or right?
No, it's definitely left.
Oh god, this is so intense now.
We're almost to the elevator.
My bitties!
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, there it is.
We got the elevator.
Stream reconnecting.
That's good.
I like that.
Sorry about that, dude.
did you lose many viewers i don't want to talk about it bro
i'm a dead streamer again bro i still have i saw 74.
nah we had twinge con bro this is the place to network those
views you had were amateur numbers compared to what you'll
get here trust me bro okay i agree nah you spitting facts
facts for real though for real for real here for me to farm
i was tripping yeah you're right i'm the goat all right
bring up my camera bring up my phone about to get make sure
i get every content possible.
Wait, it's fun.
Give it up.
You ain't got what?
It's fun!
Alright, I'll claim my badge.
Wait, maybe I can find my hero, Tyler, too.
Okay, let's take a look here.
Hmm, doesn't seem like you're partnered.
This is the partner line.
Please join the other line.
Am I I mean, I have, I fit the criteria.
And it's a kid.
I know.
Do I persuade or lie about being a partner?
Oh, shit.
I can't, I'm worried about pissing off Twitch staff.
Guys.
I am, though.
My application got accepted right before I got here.
Must not have gone through yet.
You know I can see your account details, right?
You've never applied for partnership.
right now i got the viewership for that girl okay how about
i just apply now then look i peek at 100 recently i'm
basically partner already it doesn't work that way what come
on bro cutting there's no one in this line can't you just
give me my badge here i said no go to the other line stupid
ass fuck ass rules bro you're gonna regret that right
streamer in the world partner entry only The wait in this
stupid-ass line?
What up?
Here from my entry badge.
Names Caden Brentley.
Did you just cut those people waiting before you?
Back of the line will call you up when it's your turn.
A sob story.
Please, I need to get in there.
I just lost like 200 viewers trying to get through the
garage.
Okay, when he said sob story, I feel like it'd be a bit sad.
I mean, it's 200 viewers, don't you?
Guys, this is so sad.
Like, I would not even be like, my parents died.
Like, like, that's so sad.
That's, like, the saddest story he's ever, the saddest thing
that's ever happened to in this life.
He lost 200 viewers.
Absolutely not.
Back of the line.
Please, speed, I need this.
My mom is kind of homeless.
That's not even a parody anymore.
That's not...
Why are you trying not to laugh, bruh?
That's not even a fairy!
You disrespect for this shit, bro.
Why are you laughing at me, bruh?
Okay, fine.
Here's your badge.
Yay!
It worked.
It worked, guys.
I don't know how that worked, but it worked.
Yo, off the record, why Doc really get banned?
I think we all know why you got banned, though.
He walked up to staff asking stupid fucking questions Stupid
fucking mistakes man Didn't he got i mean i didn't he got
revealed why he was bad.
It was pretty it's pretty bad.
It was pretty bad Hmm, hello.
I am streaming you are also a twin streamer feels rain man
Yeah
Yeah, no not it's an illusion, bro.
You've been smoking that good shit it wasn't a question i am
here to network in hopes of taking a portion of your viewers
from myself get away get the fuck out of here bro already
taking my view allow me to use your network for my own now
in the future i will allow you one stream with me once i've
surpassed you do we have a deal no fuck off bro no loss only
one percent of streamers actually achieve success defined a
sustainable six-figure salary with trends of growth that
perform inflation people pop people statistically you would
not be helpful i will not waste my time anymore on damn i
must you're smaller than me bro i gotta get the bro you're
smaller than me pyro software let's talk i am very yes i am
very smart bro can you take that mic out of your mouth or
whatever you're doing what are you talking about i think i'm
going through my third I'm gonna doubt him.
Oh yeah, your third, huh?
Yeah, it just seems like a very real thing.
Your doctor definitely said that.
One!
Oh wait, that's a bad, I was gonna say.
You better not be making fun of me.
These puberties are very real.
You trying to get banned?
Scared him.
Dude, there's a fire in the building.
What?
Move!
Fire!
Get out of my way!
Okay, I got- Wait, is that Tyler too?
A Tyson!
Flux of convention-goers is here.
I need to not account for this.
Yeah, I think that's him.
Yeah, I...
Guys, I think that's him.
I...
Okay.
Okay, fanboy.
Yo, Tyson.
Big fan!
That's so alpha.
Who's Harry?
Cracked.
Chat, am I out of content?
Hey, man, I'm out here doing freestyle raps for people.
Can I spit something for you?
Alright, mock him.
Bro, your bars are straight ass.
Let me spit some.
Hmm, okay then.
Let's hear what you got.
I'm gonna rap about bitches.
Yeah, I got 20 bitches in my DMs.
Twinge come to CM.
They'd be saying K to M.
Give me some more C.
Okay, yeah, I'm kidding.
no no no no i had to stop that before i had to yeah no nice
bro that was certainly interesting but it's my turn now give
me some words and i'll freestyle straight off the dome first
word kai synapse all right okay kai synapse goon all right
word goon got it one more word famine tax famine tax that's
two words but fine all right we got kai synapse goon and
famine tats i'm hairy like a crack i'm hairy like i'm back
yeah they call me kai synapse the way that as soon as i go
live the site collapse because it's like everybody want to
watch my back and they want to see what happens and i'm
gonna do it like that yeah i'm the best and not even at this
i could also do on twinge and i could do it to my dick but
i'm gonna have to goon for a second oh oh all the different
Picks and then a little hungry a little bit starving.
Yeah, we got sweet.
I think he's actually better at that than me I relax any
means possible.
I'm about to go get fat Damn that shit was fire Holy shit
Harry crack the new GTA theme that shit ain't so bad Hell,
yeah, bro Oh my god.
He was rapping for real.
But successful streamers like me have their own discorps.
After you gain some regular viewers, ask your chat to make a
server.
And someone will usually be smart enough to set one up for
you.
Twins Rivals.
Now you can start linking it to family.
My shop gape legends.
Yo, Twitch Popo.
Better not be watching me right now.
You're the attraction.
You gotta treat yourself like a grand opening every single
time.
I have a question from I overturned to be a fan oh my god
I'm your biggest fan bro I've been watching you ever since
you started I have a five-year sub badge what the hell are
they doing in deep legends yeah all right calm down buddy
now do you have a question or are you just gonna fangirl
over me or confuse him with someone else that's content bro
that's content I'm just a huge fan of your freestyles can I
give you a few words to rap with what freestyles are you
confused stream or are you just watching my viral clips i do
watch bro of course bro i love your streams let me ask you a
question then what's your favorite moment for my stream you
think he's a mine shaft player or it seems like a mine shaft
player right or or is it your jokes he seems like it won
that time when you played yeah with your friends bro when I
was playing go blocks go blocks what's the difference with
roblox I was like what the fuck oh roblox man I remember
that I was making I was making the funniest oh no this game
stinks at least sorry oh god oh no oh no it keeps go going
this game stop him there you are you ain't funny I've had
enough of this who let this maggot as well onto my panel
double down you a bitch that's right weak-ass panel nobody
even here your only person the only person here is here to
rage bait you bro if you haven't noticed i have 99 viewers
right now that puts me in the top one percent bracket of
twitch streamers what's calling bro calling broke damn pack
it up bro i heard red grilled burgers is hiring
subscribers and sponsors you couldn't dream of this level of
clout now
I don't know where to go do I mock his voice break or flex
on him I got him
one one all right there you go looks like the only thing you
cracking is your voice what does that have to do with
anything well I could I could be like I'm 17 and I have the
same amount of viewers as you.
I think...
See for yourself, bro.
I'm live at Caden Brantley.
That's right.
Sure.
Let's see about that.
Seems like you peaked two days ago.
It's all downhill from here, little brother.
What the fuck does this mean?
Do I turn on my view buds?
Yo, mods.
Call the banners.
It's time for operation to...
I might want to check again little bro I only started my
stream a bit ago my real viewers are here now wait there's
no way a mere viewer in the audience could surpass me no
your view body we're rubbing in told you you're my little
bitch that's right get on your knees for your new Sigma wolf
pack leader beta no you're a fraud no one comes to my panel
and insults me
Page bait successful.
You're just a pathetic viewer down there asking me, the real
streamer, all the questions.
All of you are pathetic viewers.
You should be honored to even listen to me talk.
I should have sub-warred this shit.
Fuck you, kid.
Fuck all of you.
I'm 17.
Yay, content.
Wait, is that not a viral clip?
That's basically a viral clip.
No!
You're a nobody!
You are!
You are a nobody!
You are you are you are a no- Yeah, I'm pretty sure that was
good.
That's gonna go viral.
I'm pretty sure.
Chat, make sure to join the Discord.
Alright, let's- We naturally- Oh, oh no.
Oh.
Okay, it's fine.
As long as we don't- I thought that was the moderator area.
Taya, do you want to fucking die?
It's okay, guys, as long as we don't touch anything, that's
lying.
Taya, sit the fuck down.
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
Sit, or I'm going to kill you.
Chat, keep a tab open to your voice.
Better leave.
Okay, I left.
Okay, I just wanted to...
gamble.
All right, I'll place my bet.
Blackjack.
Wait, I know I'll play Blackjack.
It's dead.
What?
20?
All right.
We'll do $3.
Jack, can you post my stream on Shreddit?
Okay, 10, 14.
Hit me.
Are you fucking... This is rigged.
This is fucking rigged.
third party third party third party all right we'll do
another one we can do this we can win back the money that
has to be yes 121 there's no way this is rigged as hell
yeah rotate to me hit me chat you guys have been sleeping on
this content
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, the next one, the next one will be it.
Oh my god, there's no way.
Look at that, look at that, 450, look at that, I told you
guys.
I told you.
Yes, I just got pays.
Whoa, what are you playing?
I'm trying to unlock Sierra.
What do you want?
Bro, is this a Kummer game?
Why the fuck are you playing it here?
Yeah.
It's so much more than a Kummer game, dude.
It's a turn-based strategy.
Bro, half the...
All the ladies are naked.
You should strategize how to get some hose IRL, bruh.
I don't need hose.
My sex goddesses that I've unlocked worship and milk me
whenever I please.
No, staff.
We got a fucking predator over here.
I just wanted to check my...
Oh, wait, it's over here.
I just wanted to update my mods.
Alright, who do I have?
Dude, why?
I ain't even VIP have you switching up on your day ones
already.
Let's see.
Chat.
Anyone want mod?
And I...
Oh, wait.
Wait, actually, we can get...
The cameraman.
Get mod and chat for a mod giveaway.
Now he thinks he can mod for everyone.
Passionate but clueless.
It's okay.
It's a lot better than the other mods I have.
Could forge what.
Oh, I have only one.
Oh, wait.
I can have three mods.
So are you on our side?
Eight people.
Yo, bro, I feel like I can...
Alright, let's see.
I have three mods now.
Chap, do I got aura?
I will get Gerald.
Because he gets me, like, in gains from viewer gains.
Which is good.
What you playing, bro?
Yeah, what you playing?
I'm fucking killing children in fortified.
Four out of 100 left.
holy shit we're backseat up the minigun bro you missed it
back there turn around dude shut the fuck up i got this stop
backseating me look at the chest bro yeah bro that's why you
only did four out of a hundred yeah trust me there's people
in there you were right i fucking don't this ass i fucking
won i'm gonna take credit me bro bro yeah give me some p
bucks bro go away all right i got some viewership though
from that well she there hey how long you planning to play
for um i don't know for a while there's plenty of other
computers around for how much longer bro i'm kind of in a
rush here dude i don't know for an hour why are you asking
there's a bunch of others you could use i just want it can
you get up please please leave me alone all right no viewers
from here oh he's playing counter strike what i'm playing
It's still see- wow the sequel to Counter-Strike,
Counter-Strike Co What else is there to do go tell streamers
about your dead stream and how you want to collab with them
or some shit Bro my mod's spamming, bro
Sorry I had to talk to my hero real quick man
No, it's CSO!
Who's there?
Question him.
Yeah, who are you lying for?
Uh, are you illiterate?
The sign says it's from Vapre.
She's so mid, bruh, elbows too pointy, knows at an unoptimal
angle, wouldn't.
Shut up, dude!
You wouldn't have a chance with her if you wanted!
a chance than you little bro i got mad riz no i have a
chance
who's this guy oh follow for follow hey you're streaming
aren't you no no bro fuck off no no no you are the turn is
so sick man i just got affiliated can i get a shout out no
shout out man go away going anywhere until I get that shout
out.
Bruh, get off my dick.
I'm leaving.
How do I still?
How am I still losing viewers?
Okay.
No, I'll give you your shout out and then you fuck off.
Shout out to this guy.
Go follow his channel.
Wait, I never told you my channel name.
Yeah, dope, bruh.
Bye.
Oh my god, please.
No.
Sure, sure, bruh.
Look at that.
Yeah, you're Camden, Camden.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I don't know what to do.
You don't even know my name, bruh.
Fuck off.
I'm losing viewers.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Shoot, go away.
Go away.
You're irrelevant anyway.
Actual relevant streamers are nicer than you.
Go away.
Wait, that.
Wait, who's that?
Insider.
Kid, you want to hear some secrets about your favorite
streamers?
Yeah, who hates each other?
Who hates each other?
Fuck yeah, I do.
Who beefing, bro?
100 bucks for the deets.
I don't even have $100.
I don't even have 100.
Oh my god, is that VTuber?
Is that...
a vtuber and i posted this like oh my god guys guys the
vtuber would you like a selfie oh my god it's not even her
voice acting it it's goblin club all right well knowing what
happened i should oh my god i can't because like both
options cause drama both
guys the i don't both options cost drama I don't remember I
what can I say so how about we get out of here and I all
your gear is fine shit oh wow yeah sure that sounds like a
good time what that never works why the fuck did it have to
work for the first time I'm a fucking robot man okay it's
okay my career I my career didn't get canceled Where am I
going to meet my...
No!
A few questions for you if you have the time, my man.
Okay.
Just make it fast.
I gotta find some content and you are not it.
Okay.
What's your body count?
I'm a minor.
You shouldn't ask me, bro.
I'm still 17.
Shit.
Bro!
What can I...
I'm just...
I can't get away!
Don't get away from me!
Get away from me!
Stop!
No, I don't have fighting!
I'm minor, bro.
Shut the fuck up.
Get out of here.
I spent 10k on this bad boy.
How'd you afford yours?
One exchange axe?
No.
Bro, you're killing my stream right now.
Fuck off.
So exciting to meet another droner.
I can't believe you got one too.
Did you buy the mic accessory like me?
Oh no, no.
They're siphoning my viewers.
No, get me out of it.
Oh shit!
The viewers that I worked so hard on It's now a horde.
Wait, is that case?
Oh wait, he's back.
Yo, bruh, you want to play a game of would you rather?
Sure.
Why not?
Case so number two.
Um, zoomer or gen a brain rot.
Zoomer.
Zoomer rot, bruh.
Amogus is peak.
Exactly, bro.
500 duck-sized bears or one bear-sized duck?
One bear-sized duck.
I can just stomp him.
bro fuck is a duck yeah have no internet access or have
painfully slow internet forever huh would i still be able to
stream with a slow internet no it'd be too slow to do stuff
like that i already still have the internet all this just
dial up the slow internet bro what just become a slip-slop
influencer or some shit what do we mean no internet streamer
with a community that you good chat.
I want to love my community.
Small streamer with the good chat.
Yeah.
I love my little pets.
Become the smartest person in the world or the dumbest.
Your intelligence doesn't change.
Everyone else's does.
I'd be the dumbest.
The smart people can take care of me.
Because if I'm the smartest person and then I'm surrounded
by people dumber than me, that's like really bad and i have
to take care of all the other like it's like that what was
that it's like that cult film i forgot it's called where the
guy wakes up and becomes the smartest person on earth only
because the rest of the world got really really dumb uh the
dumbest mathematically that mean everyone else becomes
smarter than me which means currently they're all dumber
yeah maths yeah idiocracy yeah yeah yeah last one sit or
stand to watch what What?
Standers got PB and JS on God.
Wait, who fucking?
I'm sorry, but I'm okay.
I shouldn't ask that question to you guys.
Okay.
I'm gonna keep beating now.
I'm like, who's that?
Oh god.
Oh wait, she needs help.
I don't know where to go.
I know, I'm like, who's that?
What do you mean?
Are you lost?
No, there's just too much shit.
I don't know what to do.
I could get in the meeting reliance.
I could go to see the booths.
This attorney and a giveaway at the same time and a game
show at five demo booths.
Oh my god, there's so many options at TwinsCon.
I'd have to go downstairs and around the convention for the
food trucks.
The food here is shit.
Okay, I'll help there.
Yo, bro, fuck all that shit.
Just follow me around.
I'll choose what we do.
One catch.
You gotta entertain my stream while you follow me and farm
me some viewers.
All right, we got a cameraman.
Oh, that'd be nice.
I'd love a new convention friend.
You'd be more like an assistant a pet Oh, that sounds fun.
I guess I'll just see some brain rot shit
All right, we got it.
Oh, wait.
I have to get a top score.
All right.
Let's okay.
We I can get 26.
It's 26 points Should be fine You guys we actually have to
we actually have to get the top score for this.
It's okay.
We can do it Yes, I just got the ace Okay, it's now 29.
It's 29.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Maya, please stop existing.
No.
We're almost there, guys.
We're almost there.
It's almost there, guys.
Guys, it's just one more to go.
Just one more to go, guys.
We're so close.
the end oh wait i don't have to tap it okay it's just just
press what what is the oh my god what is the hitbox oh my
gosh she's latina
okay we're almost there guys we're almost here one more one
more to go one more to go okay 16 one more guys one more
we're almost there
oh no oh no oh no okay 20 oh
I gotta lock in we gotta lock in we gotta we gotta make it
and we get so many viewers after that five 26 yo who's
trying to sponsor me 27
28 okay we're here okay
yes i'm going to kill you we did it Um, I don't, I didn't
mean to time it like that.
Uh, I didn't mean to have it timed to end it there.
Yo, what up, scheme?
Big damn, bruh.
Oh, go ahead.
Say your jokes already.
Everyone else already has.
What you talking about, bro?
What the cooking you about?
Wait.
You're not gonna joke about my mind shaft speed runs.
I don't give a fuck, bro.
Do you got any content for me?
Oh, wow.
Uh, you're streaming this.
I take it.
Yeah, bro.
I stream my entire life and I never turned it off.
Yeah, I got like 5,000 views on twinge.
So like, what do you do when you goon or have sex?
Do you?
Bro, I'm a minor, bro.
I'm 17, bro.
Quit being cis.
Yeah, it's fucking weird, bro.
It's- It's that stream?
It just clicked on me because he talked about- I was like,
I'm a minor, bro.
What are you, dream or something?
And then it clicked on my head.
Wait, that is dream.
Oh, shit.
Yo, I didn't know.
Anybody watching this, that was a joke.
Put the bass back on.
I was gonna say- Anyway, I got a big comeback stream planned
for January.
I just hope they forgive me for the speedrunning shit.
they won't insult him maybe you shouldn't have faked your
speed runs bro oh you think i wasn't gonna come clean about
it eventually i was just doing it for content like you fuck
you bro my content yeah my all my viewers are 100 real and
not viewbot or ai right chat damn bro you got some brat
energy for real that's good don't let this industry change
you You need some real content.
No more mineshaft sleeper shit.
I can give you some content pointers, bro.
So true.
You are so funny, Doki Bird.
I wish I can like and subscribe your channel again because
you make me LOL so hard right now that I am ROLFing right
now on my desk.
You know what?
That sounds good, man.
I could use a friend in this fucked up industry.
is empty anyways let's get out of here here take the spare
pass and meet me at the park oh my gosh free free entry to
partner see i was so real to him look at that i was so real
that i get to go into the partner lounge now can i go
through this door no
all right
You know what?
61616161616161616161 Edgemaster Google Complex Fuck, bro,
I'm losing viewers to you right now You're brain rotting Oh
my god, he's more brain rotting than me Did I eat?
Okay, fuck Okay, we can't we can't lose more viewers We
gotta go to the partner lounge All right, there we go.
Playboy, wait, PVC.
Kraken popping.
Tamian.
Andre.
Where's scheme?
Chat, I'm your favorite streamer, right?
Teezy beat you!
Did she mean?
pirate software or pyro software is that train tracks there
was a fire there was nothing i could possibly do look at the
fire extinguishers they're empty fucking shameless i don't
even know who to talk to first let's see you pubbo hey
what's up mate yo pubbo big fan bro my friend gerard loves
man i can't be mean a pubble man pubble is like so he just
plays minecraft that's all he does wait is that oh i thought
that was tommy in it that's tammy in it
i don't know who to talk to i don't who to it's so awkward
wait like i've interacted with half of these people before i
died i I'm like, I'm, I'm stuck in a bad place right now.
I, every interaction matters.
I'm, I'm, I,
I, fuck, I, I am a priest.
I play priest between rock and a.
hard place want to join do it for the content don't
understand yeah bro i'm level a thousand right now what he's
like excuse me sign a motherfucking thing i'm not the one
not what i did not that's a single motherfucking thing and i
just continued to go and then i came with the bottom line
and i really i'm the i'm the man man it's that that is why
they call me that's actually a really great a really great
Nation
That's a really good impression I will have to say that's a
really good impression.
I will have to say that's a really good impression Dude, I'm
your biggest fan bro.
I watched you in the uber watch days.
Oh my god Jesus Christ dude That was a fucking long time ago
man.
Wait, it got missed to do it.
No fucking wonder I was like wait that impression is
actually pretty good They actually got Miffed to do it.
Listen here.
Listen here, fucking Bozo.
I got your house on my motherfucking wrist, dude.
Okay, look.
First of all, okay, look at, look.
You shouldn't even be in here.
Okay, first of all, look at the fucking badge.
That doesn't even say your name.
How the fuck do you even get in?
It doesn't even make any 거 concentrated sense.
Okay, security here.
It's fucking trash.
Look what happened.
You remember what happened to everyone?
That is crazy.
It doesn't even fit the character right now.
anymore oh dude this fucking guy man okay look i'm trying to
talk to my friend here dude what the fuck do you want what
i'll talk to the people that i i'm no like not like no no
but like i i don't know who okay wait i don't know who andre
topaz or oh wait are they the chess sisters is that but i
know much about them because i don't watch that that content
because i'm too dumb for chess as someone that actually used
to be in the chess club i
i'm worried if i reserve people are gonna cancel me yo tammy
big fan i love how you're like What's up, dude?
Why you look all cracked out, bruh?
Are you one of them?
Yes.
For sure, bruh.
I'm one of them.
Okay, well, logically, if you were one of them, you wouldn't
fucking tell me you were one of them.
So, uh, I think you probably aren't one of them.
I'm just looking for content, dude.
Oh, so you are one of them.
I gotta stop trusting people in this fucking industry, dude.
Fucking shameless.
Yeah, I know it's triggering your ex.
I know.
I'm worried about talking to I'm worried about talking to
this guy I'm not I'm worried I'm worried about I'm just
worried oh wait that's Jason don't we know it is like one of
the IRL content creators what's up man oh is that the
girlfriend ex-girlfriend yo bro so uh Jackura.
We know that ain't ever gonna work.
Let's just get it over with and you can give me her number.
Damn!
Bro, you serious?
Bro, you're serious?
Okay.
Oh, hello.
I can't, guys.
I- I can't.
Holy shit, Daisy.
I'm your biggest fan.
I love your music.
Oh, thank you.
Panda to your chat.
Nicely.
Yo, so my chat is wondering.
No, what do you mean?
Oh, my...
Please, leave me alone.
What?
I didn't realize my chat was asking about her.
Oh, my God.
I didn't read chat.
I read you guys.
I didn't read my other chat.
There's too many chats to read.
I backed up.
Hello.
Nice to meet you.
Holy fuck!
Digi, I'm your biggest fan.
I have posters and pillows of you all over my room.
Oh, wow.
Thank you.
That's sweet.
Guys, I read- I can't- I- I- guys.
Wait, Michael.
Where's Michael?
You got- you got- you're not supposed to be streaming in
here you know all right let's see everybody hey bro what's
good i never i don't know who this guy is so i'm gonna no
bro just being real your music ass bro no cap you streaming
this man get the hell out of here bro i guess what i did all
right i can still hear god i'm so hot
um hello so you trying to cosplay as my girl or what shoddy
um no thank you that's kind of weird dude are you fucking
kidding me your cosplay oh my god what okay uh bye oh fuck
no like okay i didn't realize i would i just i was like make
her angry i didn't think that's what he's gonna do by making
All right, yo center fine shit.
You fuck with white bro.
Who the fuck even are you?
We had to stop there.
We had to stop there because then I remembered he's he's 17.
We had I I
All right, I'll try to impress her getting good at checkers
lately undefeated oh that's great you know what i could beat
you yeah sure mr elo grad master in overwatch i'm
grandmaster bruh number one in the world okay i'm gonna stop
talking to you now hey what about you i'm gonna talk about
her sister because i'm 17.
i like your sister andrea more than you
lovely good for you i'll be there okay there oh that that's
what he means what that was that's what he means you just
can't move it are you even allowed to be here don't dodge
what i said andrea's better than you double down to she's
technically not better on paper but why are you trying to
make me talk about her so you're saying you're better than
her chat clip that holy shit you are so weird get out of
here all right oh fuck is that everybody oh fuck okay
tiny ass legs bro small is your head it's the it's the least
worst out of two options is these legs take a good look yeah
they're huge nice try I was just joking you was you know
what's funny this is one of the few that doesn't show the
voice actor even he doesn't want to be credited right now he
no I got so many people thirsting over me yeah he doesn't
want to be credited I I got little scared yo there he is
have you gotten a chance to talk with the partners here yet
yeah didn't really want to talk though good ending good
ending told you i may cheat but i don't lie all they care
about is viewers by the way are you streaming in here you're
not allowed to
turn stream off lie tell him you're not streaming lie what
they're both the same gonna look up my stream dude dude dude
you should lie and the lie often sounds good yeah he's just
maybe you should with just live one is a lie and the other
one is a better lie
oh hi bro i'm turning it off now There, I'm offline now.
So, you really want to become a streamer, right?
Yes.
I genuinely, it's the only thing I want, bruh.
Well, stick with me, and only me.
Do you understand?
I can make you the biggest streamer on the platform.
Hmm.
How you gonna do that, bruh?
well my philosophy is if you really want something you go
for it and what I want is right in front of me tonight huh
is that something you can do I don't feel comfortable with
this guy I think I need an adult I think I need an adult
guys guys i guys do we follow scheme or um do we ask some
questions
because i don't know if i feel comfortable around it he is
the adult can i get another adult please What?
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
Don't act coy.
No need to play hard again.
I know what you want and I have a feeling you know what I
want to
Bro, you trying to ris me up Come on all the fun is ruined
when you spell it out like that
I think we're on the wrong side quest guys.
I I I'm here from LSF
What the fuck?
I am a minor.
You know I'm a minor, right?
You said you were what?
I mean, age of consent in most states is 16.
17.
It ain't a big deal.
You're basically an adult.
What the fuck?
Can't lie.
I don't know what capitalized means.
What does this mean?
what does what does the cat what does cat lies even do I
want you and I to have just a little innocent fun I'll give
you my hotel room number and you can meet me there later
what do you say oh you're done for bozo the whole world's
gonna know you're a pedo now right and who's gonna believe
you do you know how many people who try to cancel me every
day yeah differences my stream was on this whole time what
you you told me your stream was off security security this
this kid is streaming in here when they said get a viral
clip i didn't realize what kind of clip i was getting
Look at that view castle No, guys, I misunderstood okay like
when he said he was a minor.
I thought he was like he mine like in mine chat Like I was
trying to teach him speed running.
Oh I'm fucking famous not sexually The monkey paw girls
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you
The kids...
You're in for the mine!
Whoa!
Alright, Gerald, I'm ready to go back.
And Gerald, I think I'm done at TwitchCon.
Wait, where's Gerald?
Wait, where is Gerald?
wait where the fuck is jared i don't know where i left him
chat make sure to keep a tab open for me where the fuck did
i left my homeboy
oh he was where i am oh he's at the vip oh fuck quick
question bro what's your network why do you want to know
No, you're not okay.
No, my viewers
Wait, he's back in the VIP.
Oh my god, Gerald.
No, he died when I was born.
He was actually my twin I was born.
Maybe my mom lied to me.
Get away.
Go away.
Go away Holy fuck.
Oh, no, no, my view Gerald.
Why did you tell me you're here?
You ain't gonna believe it.
I just hit a clip of scheme trying to groom me I'm at the
top of shred it no fucking way really I'm so dead ass bruh
scheme ducks the fuck out when he realized what was
happening Yeah, my ticket out of dead streamer arc, bro.
Fuck moving to us and we skipping straight to LA right See I
told you I was like I thought everybody lived in LA now LA
streamer house and shit.
Oh My god streamer house time.
I'll be the next phase glad Before they all before they went
bankrupt
Let's go!
Spend your donation money on gambling or view bots or both.
One year later, Los Angeles, California.
Please,
Kaden, sign me up.
I gotta go outside.
I have to.
I've been hard-stuck 3K subs, bro fuck it I gotta bring back
the IRL wait 5 million hours watch oh I've just been gaming
when I moved to LA you would think he would like be outside
more that now that he is in LA I'll save sleep stream well I
should be able to have more mods now right oh wait I'm
partnered now oh Oh, shit.
Okay, I can still only have three mods.
Let me, I'll make this pop.
Okay, I think we're fine right now.
I still have a mug on these other boring ass streamers, bro.
Alright.
Alright, what kind of stream?
Oh, hey.
Marv.
Who's Marv?
Subcated?
Guess what, dude?
My subs jump from 800 to 1200 in one week.
Did you pay rent, bro?
Rents do, so I'm gonna need that new sub money.
Your bald ass was late on your shit by a week last time.
Bro, I just ordered a new Skyset apps drone yesterday.
Gimme till my next Twinge pay check hits and I got you.
Bro, why the hell did you get a drone?
I pulled my drone out of the closet today and I'm starting
the IRL shit again.
You trying to copy me?
No, dude, I didn't know.
I thought you were doing the card opening stuff still.
Whatever, bro.
Just remember to not stream while I'm live.
fucking serious.
You do it again accidentally and you're out of the house.
Heartstar is already at 5k.
I need 30k viewers.
Holy shit, where am I gonna get 30k?
What's this?
Oh, we're gambling.
Wait, I have 5k viewers and I still only have a hug.
What am I spending?
What the fuck am I spending?
Feels... Oh, wait, Rayman!
He came back do the thing yes what do you need i'm currently
streaming my average viewers have jumped from 1800 to 2200
in one week must be the subathon my slipsops have been well
recently too posted a fortified victor arrault compilation
recently and it hit 300 000 viewers today and if i wrap my
subathon early this week my viewers will probably make a
shred it post about how it's a failure makes for a good
recap content yesterday kai synapsis mod hosted me and it
turned into an offline Not what I expected, but I expect
this to increase my weekly rules by 32% this guy knows how
to stream Okay, don't piss me off, bro.
Remember the rules.
You stay under my viewer account or else we're gonna have a
problem Why did I even host this guy?
Why did I let him live here?
My goat feels raiment.
That's my Ochi right there.
You got me blow.
I'm all out my dealers Loki ghost in my ass Wait, I made my
friend that into a oh no oh no bro you have a problem bro
all you've been doing is coke you got a problem man all i've
been doing you gotta be capping dude you forget that i've
been managing your useless ass this whole year what do you
imagine we're both oh we're 18 now we're both 18.
oh no i made him an addict you would have slipped into
irrelevancy after that scheme clip that ain't true fuck off
bro i got that clip on my own.
That's right.
You ain't doing shit.
Sponsors setting up collabs and other sellout bullshit.
Yeah, I don't need that.
I can get that myself.
Yeah, that bullshit is the reason we got a house dumbass.
Shut your ass up and lock in.
Your view count got no movement right now.
I heard the president is visiting here soon.
What?
That wall that opened across the street is part of his bring
back jobs from India project or some shit.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna stop here before oh my god guys wow i feel like
wow i've been streaming for so long guys i i'm so tired
everyone i'm guys i i'm i'm i'm tired now wow i've been i
i'm getting i realized why i've been streaming for three and
a half hours
I realize I gotta stop here because I have so much work
to...
I have to do.
I actually do have so much work to do.
So, I guess, you know, I gotta fix my sleep schedule too.
Oh, man, won't we know what was gonna happen in LA?
But don't you think about the cop?
I realize, wow, I have...
I realize, well, I've been swimming for a while, so I should
call it here because...
you know, we have a lot of fun streams for this week, so,
you know, we gotta, there's just so much to do.
Anyway, guys, wow!
I really, you know, I guess, I don't know, I just, wow, that
game was wild.
That game was wild.
maybe one day I'll be the content apparently I'm still
learning I'm still just a little little baby when it comes
to content guys hey guys I'm in college here as always
everybody is stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around and get that blood flow you stay up for me head to
bed because you deserve it I'll see you guys next time Bye,
guys. Bye.